isolated and lonely
in their later years
as many of us have said this afternoon
she was our rock
but i want to look at in my brief
contribution who was her rock
and i would commend to uh all honourable
members here the book that was uh
published in honor of her 90th birthday
uh the servant queen and the king she
serves it's published by the bible
society and the clue is rather in the
name of the book
she lived out her faith and she did so
with humility
and with grace
and with kindness but she also wasn't
afraid to speak about it either as she
did in her christmas broadcast in 2002
when she said as follows
i know just how much i rely on my faith
to guide me through the good times and
the bad
each day is a new beginning
i know that the only way to live my life
is to do what is right
to take the long view
to give of my best in all that the day
brings
and to put my trust in god i draw
strength from the message of hope in the
christian gospel
and it was her faith that enabled her to
take the long view and as the daughter
and uh
wife of a naval officer she had the
attitude that this storm too shall pass
when she was facing current difficulties
which can seem to overwhelm us sometimes
she took the long view and it was her
faith that enabled her to face her end
calmly
because she knew that thinking death is
the end is the great lie of the evil one
so may she rest in peace
and rise in glory and i look forward to
the reign of his majesty king charles
iii who cares passionately for the
well-being of all peoples across these
islands and who has been way ahead of
his time on issues like climate change
and the environment
god save the king
colleen fletcher thank you
thank you very much
can i rise
to pay tribute
to
her late majesty the queen elizabeth ii
on behalf of myself and the people in my
constituency
in coventry
for all of us individually and
collectively this is a moment of great
sorrow and profound national sadness as
we mourn the loss of queen elizabeth ii
our longest reigning and most remarkable
monarch who always displayed an
unwavering commitment and steadfast
devotion to our nation and the
commonwealth
for over seven decades the queen has
been a symbol of stability and
continuity and ever-present part of the
fabric of national life for so many of
us me included
she was the only monarch we have ever
known and was a constant presence
throughout our lifetime
indeed as our society our country and
the wider world has changed beyond all
recognition around us she was a
reassuring presence of solidity and
constancy
throughout her reign
the queen certainly made her mark on the
city of coventry she first visited
coventry in 1948 to inaugurate the new
city center and lay the foundation stone
of the new shopping precinct as the city
recovered from the devastation of war
and the blitz on coventry
thereafter she visited coventry on
several other occasions most notably for
the consecration of the new cathedral in
1962 i remember that very well as a
child we all went along from school the
opening of the newly refurbished walls
grave hospital in 1970 and latterly for
the home front exhibition at the herbert
art gallery and museum in the year 2000
it was on this occasion that i met the
queen i was a councillor in coventry and
took along my elderly mother-in-law val
to meet her too even though val was
extremely nervous she was able to chat
to the queen about life in coventry
during the war val never forgot that day
for the rest of her life and spoke about
it often and watching val i strongly
sensed people's allegiance and love for
the queen and her family
so during those visits and the many
others the queen made to the city she
left a lasting legacy in the city of
coventry and enduring memories for its
residents who i know
will feel an overwhelming sense of loss
following her passing
her majesty queen elizabeth ii was a
devoted wife
mother grandmother and great-grandmother
and a much cherished monarch
her life was one of extraordinary
dedication and service and her loss
will be felt in every corner of our
nation and right across the world
rest in peace your majesty
vicky ford
speaker
i remember as a child being given a
large pair of scissors
a huge stack of well-thumbed magazines
and been asked to make a massive collage
of pictures of the queen and her family
it was the silver jubilee and there
didn't seem to be any arrangement for a
party so my mother had decided to fling
open the doors and hold her fate
we wrapped up presents to put in a lucky
dip
i think we even arranged to have a candy
floss machine
and somebody bought some ponies for pony
rice
but we didn't know if people would come
and i wanted to tell this story because
this was in oma
in northern ireland in 1977
in the middle of the troubles
and the people came
and they came in their hundreds
they came from all walks of life
the protestants came the catholics came
and they came
because they loved
our queen
and people love
our queen
she has been the rock beneath our feet
in trouble's time and the light that has
shown us the way in the darkness
they love her in chelmsford they love
her across the country and they love her
across the world
during my
political career i've had the
opportunity to travel to many countries
and especially so in the past year and i
have felt that love and fondness again
and again
but it is in particularly in many
developing countries where i have felt
the love and respect and gratitude
because every christmas message in so
many of those visits and events she has
used her voice to speak out for the most
vulnerable and make sure their voices
are heard
and as the development minister that she
appointed earlier this week
it is that legacy that i pledge
to continue
for her
but i also know how much love and
respect there is for our new monarch
king charles iii
especially for his work on the
environment and climate change
my condolences my thoughts my prayers
are with him
and with his family
and i look forward
to his reign
god save the king
jess phillips
thank you madam deputy speaker um very
much like the prime minister i was not
raised in a house of monarchists
um and
yesterday when the first news came of
the queen's ill health i was on um bill
committee in the security bill and
i i was surprised by how deeply affected
i felt by the news
i
was
extremely emotional immediately and it
felt to me like that phone call that
almost everybody who has lost somebody
close to them gets
that says
get here soon now's the time
and that's what it felt like and i it
made me reflect why do i feel like this
and it was because
it feels as if
the queen was a member of every one of
our families
even a family like mine
um
she it
we can project our own life no matter
how different that life is to the one
that the queen had
we all feel able to project our own life
her universal experience
feels like ours
and she feels like she is with us all
and that made me reflect on all the
stories that we've i'm sure we've all
been reading
and there is a story about the queen's
grace for everybody
and anyone no matter what your political
persuasion your religion whatever
floats your boat
you can find something a story going
around at the moment about the queen
that
leads to your bias
um and
yeah she was clever like that's an
incredible skill
um and shows what an icon and a diplomat
she was you can see her as a
traditionalist you can see her as a
modernist you can see her
as
um
somebody with deep faith you can see her
as somebody who represented well people
without a faith
but what i have found
is that the queen
was a feminist
um
and this is
uh the brilliant story about the crown
prince of saudi arabia being driven
around very very
quite roughly by the queen around the
balmoral estate when um women in saudi
arabia were not allowed to drive
is one of my top stories but i saw this
story and it said when the queen came to
open the rolls building she was ushered
into a room in which we were waiting uh
in which way were all the judges she
looked at the ermine clad ranks of
chancery judges smiled and crisply said
where are the women
a look of panic crossed multiple faces
until someone saw three female chancery
district judges in a dark corner there
they are he shouted so the queen went to
talk to them
what
a woman
what a leader
that everybody no matter what sort of
family they grew up in no matter which
bit of the world
everybody feels that they have a tiny
little bit of her
with us
god rest the queen
albert acosta
thank you madam deputy speaker
in april 2017 as mp for south
leicestershire i had the honour of
meeting her late majesty the queen
and his late highness prince philip
when the queen hosted lunch for a small
gathering at st martin's house in
leicester following the royal monday
service in leicester cathedral
along with the prince she was extremely
gracious
listening with interest to the issues
affecting leicester and leicestershire
and thanking those within our local
community who do so much in the many
charities in our area
it was a moment of great joy to have
personally witnessed the late queen at
work
by placing duty at the forefront of
everything she did
she was a role model of how public
service should be conducted
madam deputy speaker on behalf of the
chairman and councillors of the town and
parish councils of south leicestershire
the chairman of harbor district council
councillor neil bannister and his fellow
harbour councillors
the chairman of blaby district
councillor councillor ian hewson
the leicestershire county councillors of
my constituency
on behalf of all my constituents
and of my family my wife maria
daughter sophie
and son alexander
as the member of parliament for south
leicestershire
i want to give thanks for the seven
decades of public service
given by our late queen
and may i express my sincere condolences
to his majesty the king
and the royal family
god save the king
liz kendall
on behalf of the people of leicester
west
i would like to send our deepest
sympathy and condolences
to his majesty the king and the royal
family
they have lost their mother
grandmother and great-grandmother as
well as their sovereign
and i hope the fact the whole nation
grieves alongside them
provide some small comfort at this
difficult time
queen elizabeth
was a simply remarkable public servant
unparalleled in our lifetime
who always put her people and country
first
she dedicated her life to duty and to
others
it was never ever about herself
and i think it is this selfless service
why she holds such a unique place in our
history and hearts and what she'll be
remembered for most of all
her astonishing reign saw changes
unimaginable 70 years ago
her constant calm presence
gave us stability through turbulent
times and her words of wisdom provided
perspective and strengthened our resolve
i think in particular of her address to
the nation during the covid pandemic
the queen reminded us how families had
been separated during the second world
war that this was painful
but the right thing to do
and she also rightly said this challenge
was different from the war because in
this instance we would join with nations
across the globe in a common endeavor to
beat the virus
there is nothing more powerful
then hope for a better future
and that better days lie ahead and that
is what the queen gave us so many times
finally many honourable members will
know that i represent a very diverse
constituency and as my honorable friend
the member for leicester south said we
were absolutely thrilled when the queen
decided to begin her diamond jubilee
tour in leicester 10 years ago
her majesty's loss
will be felt in every community and by
those of every faith
as well as those with none
christian hindu sikh muslim jewish and
jain
the queen stood for the values we all
share for what we hold in common not
what divides us
as does his majesty the king
i saw this when he visited the naba road
in my constituency often called the most
diverse street in the country with more
than 20 different nationalities along
the way it was a huge day and he was
welcomed with excitement joy and open
arms as i'm sure he will be as annu king
it just remains for me to send my
constituents thoughts and prayers to the
royal family
our thanks to the late queen for all she
gave
and to say on before behalf of us all
long live king charles iii
helen wakeley
thank you madam deputy speaker on behalf
of my constituents of faustian and
mid-kent i'll echo the moving words we
just heard from king charles iii
your late majesty the queen
thank you
and may you rest
in peace
a rest truly earned through a lifetime
of service
most of us across our country cannot
remember a time before her majesty queen
elizabeth she's been a constant in a
changing and often dangerous world a
source of strength
and steadfastness
a leader by example with the courage to
carry on whatever the storm and she
showed us that strength and courage need
not be
at the expense of kindness or
indeed humor and she touched the lives
of so many people in the uk and around
the world old and young alike i am sure
we have all been asked when visiting
primary schools
have you met the queen
in fact more often than were asked have
you met the prime minister
sadly my answer to the first of those
questions has always been
no
but i do have something that i'm very
personally grateful to her for
during the pandemic her majesty the
queen addressed the nation it was a dark
time and i remember her address very
well not only for the compassion and
hope she expressed but for one
particular detail
as care minister
i was endeavoring to get social care
staff thought of and talked about on a
par with staff in the nhs
when i heard the queen was going to make
an address
i sought to get a message to her
i don't know to the state if it reached
her but what mattered
is when she got to that section of her
address when she spoke
of healthcare staff she spoke of health
and social care staff
in the same breath
and she realized how important her woods
were to be to those care workers across
the country
and that brought tears to my eyes
after the bleak time of the pandemic she
then brought our communities together
for her jubilee a joyful celebration of
what we have in common
as a nation we mourn her
but her family are first and foremost in
my thoughts as a morning mother a
grandmother and a great-grandmother
i wish them strength and solace in a
life so long and well-lived
and our thoughts
are with our new king
we know
he will serve a passion and dedication
and on behalf of my constituents i wish
him strength and good fortune as he
takes on the responsibilities of our
head of state
long live the king
barry gardner
this morning i was walking to the
station at wembley central and an afghan
lady stopped me
her english was um
well let's just say it wasn't much
better than my pashtun
but through her accent i heard her say
you are mp yes
i said i was and asked if i could help
her in any way
she shook her head and left me confused
because i thought i heard her say
i at green party
sorry
then she moved on
it took me a few moments to work out
what she was actually saying
she wasn't making a statement about her
political affiliation
but saying that she had been at
the queen's party one of the glorious
street parties we held in brent for the
platinum jubilee
and in that simple word
sorry
she wanted to express her condolences
and share her own sorrow at the death of
her late majesty the queen
in brent we like to claim that we're the
most diverse place in the world
it may even be true we speak more than
160 languages around the dinner tables
we've welcomed generations of immigrants
people who came to build a better life
for their children asylum seekers like
that lady from afghanistan
she spoke for every one of my
constituents in brett
when she said
i
at queen's party
sorry
every year for more than 40 years
my family has had a ritual
no matter whether the turkey is ready or
not christmas dinner has to be finished
in time to watch the queen's speech at
three
i hope it doesn't seem disrespectful but
we used to grade them
was it as good as last year
would she
focus on something new this time
there would be
mentions of charities and visits to
communities celebrating significant
anniversaries or suffering from
disasters
but two things were constant
the commonwealth
and her own deep
very personal faith in jesus christ
which was the guiding principle of her
life
many have spoken of her life as a
pattern of duty and service and it was
but the virtues which in my view her
life so manifestly displayed
are what christians call
the fruits of the spirit
love
joy
peace patience
kindness
goodness
faithfulness
meekness
temperance
and the simple says
against such there is no law
integrity is not a very fashionable
thing in public sphere these days
but her life was one of real integrity
we thank god that she brought all those
virtues together in her life
it was a life that was selfless
it was a life
that was whole
and now
it is complete
may her soul rest in peace
and may god save the king
james cartilage thank you i'm david
speaker and it is an honor to be called
to speak on this somber day
and on behalf of the people of south
suffolk i send my condolences to the
royal family
and his majesty king charles iii now
like our previous prime minister i want
to start by making a confession because
i've never had the great honor to meet
the queen in the true sense
but i did work for her once
because in my student days my student
holidays
i was a kitchen porter for garden of
merchant
and one christmas uh in the early 1990s
i was recruited to do a 19-hour shift at
buckingham palace for the queen's staff
christmas party
it did not end well
because in the early hours luckily no
one else around concluding the tidying
up i managed to upend an entire bottle
of red wine over one of the queen's
presumably very expensive carpets
now what does one do in this situation
total panic sets in
fear of being sent to the tower of
london
so i did the only thing you can do in
that situation
a few meters away was a very large ming
bars
and i simply relocated it
for all i know because i've heard
nothing since it's still there
sorry mom
so i pledge uh my loyalty to his majesty
and i hope that he is merciful and
resists the temptation to put an invoice
for cleaning costs
in the post
and i just want to say one
thing above all else which is to express
the great privilege that i feel to have
lived in the reign of queen elizabeth ii
the great fortune i feel that my four
children lived as elizabethans and knew
what it was like to live under this
extraordinary sovereign
deservedly loved and adored the world
over for her total devotion to our
nation and our commonwealth
may she rest in peace supported in her
sleep by our eternal love and affection
god save the king
laila moran
thank you madam deputy speaker and it is
a true honour
to be able to pay tribute to the late
queen elizabeth ii on behalf of my
constituents in oxford west and abingdon
and i restate the deep sorrow and
sadness that many have already
expressed the ties between
the queen and the community were strong
indeed in every milestone of her reign
abingdon celebrated with an eccentric
and much loved bun throwing
and she was a regular visitor to our
area she inspected a military parade at
raf abingdon in 1968.
she opened sophos at abingdon science
park in 2000 and four and reopened the
ashmolean museum in oxford after its
refurbishment
in 2009
one constituent remembered the following
when he attended the official opening of
the jet fusion facility at cullum
he said it was opened jointly by the
queen and president mitterrand and as i
recall the queen spoke first
first in english
and then in very polished french a
wonderful way to open a european
project another constituent remembered
we were privileged to meet the queen in
malaysia when we lived there
i took my six-year-old daughter who was
so excited to meet the real queen and
held a bouquet for her and when the
queen approached
my daughter reluctant to release the
flowers asked
are you sure you're the real queen
you're not wearing a crown only a hat
and the queen replied
i am sorry the queen was a little heavy
to wear today but i hope you like my hat
and my daughter now convinced released
the flowers
i will always remember her warmth and
humor while handling my daughter's
mistake
and what these stories i think show is
not just her gargantuan work ethic but
also
how her humility and humanity
earned people's loyalty i'm really
struck
by how many peoples have been saying i'm
not a monarchist
but i loved her
the fact that she held people's respect
despite
not because of her title
is testament to the genius that she
brought to the role and as an example to
us all
now i'm sure many haven't got their
heads around what life is going to be
like without her
and people have mentioned stamps and
coins for me
as a brit
who grew up abroad actually it's the
portraits
when we lived in ethiopia in the 80s
we'd gather as a community at the
british club or at the embassy and there
she was
glorious in oils gazing down on our
festivities from some ornate framed
picture
and in jamaica in the 90s i remember
visiting other schools as part of an
orchestra practicing both the british
and jamaican national anthems in
preparation for her state visit where of
course she too was head of state
and there she was again
on the walls the pictures smaller often
and more humble
but always there
through time and space she was always
there
taken almost for granted binding her
people together
until yesterday
when she wasn't anymore
and like many others i'm sure
i cried
so my thoughts today are firmly with her
family and especially king charles at
this incredibly difficult time
now our loyalty transfers to him
and after his pitch perfect address
just this afternoon
i think that shows we have absolutely
nothing to fear
so may our beloved queen rest in peace
and god save the king here here
george freeman
thank you
speaker on behalf of the people of mid
norfolk i want to send our deepest
condolences to all the royal family her
late majesty's many friends and the
royal household
and echo the comments of the previous
speaker and pay tribute to
the king's spine tingling tribute to his
mother we heard a little earlier this
news has stopped the country in its
tracks all of us as many colleagues have
said whether we were lucky enough to
have met her majesty or not feel that
we've lost
our own much-loved grandmother but also
something very precious a part of us
a part of our nation
we stopped the clocks and the political
debates out of profound respect for our
longer-serving monarch
who was head of state on the throne has
guided our nation through the most
extraordinary 70 years
celebrated in the jubilee so sincerely
by a grateful nation earlier this year
and how wonderful that she had a chance
to see that gratitude but our nation
also mourns a remarkable woman
who has become quite simply as
my right honourable friend the prime
minister put it this nation's rock
as the mother grandmother great
grandmother and figurehead not just of
the royal family
but to all her subjects regardless of
faith race or any other creed across
this great nation
through tumultuous times she has been a
shining beacon of dedication to duty
office public service
and nationhood the exemplary spirit and
embodiment of the very best of the
united kingdom
a unifying sea anchor stabilizing our
ship of state in often turbulent seas
always cheered as today by masked crowds
wherever
she traveled
nowhere more may i say than in her
beloved county royal county of norfolk
where through her home at sandringham
she and her family have always been held
proudly in very close affection and
esteem
not least by the many serving and former
members of the armed forces
in our county and country
and which it's been the privilege of my
life to represent in her parliaments and
serve as a minister of the crown under
her last three prime ministers
who among us will forget the rye smile
with which
in 2012 she remarked at her golden
jubilee address
to
will remember both houses assembled in
westminster hall and to a ride chuckle
addressed as uh
addressing as she was six former prime
ministers on the front row when she said
she'd had the privilege of having been
served by 12 prime ministers
and doubtless she said at the top of her
glasses there will be many more to come
perhaps she could see the next decade
coming
the many eloquent tributes in particular
for my writing from the prime minister
member for oxbridge maidenhead ronda and
peckham have highlighted the many
virtues and legacies of our dear late
queen elizabeth indeed the great i won't
repeat them i wanted to highlight three
very particular legacies close to my
microstitchings hearts the first
children the queen understood and
believed deeply that all of us in public
office have a special duty to the
children who are our future they can't
vote or make their case in this chamber
they need us to speak for them and she
famously said
children teach us all a lesson just as
the christmas story does that in the
birth of a child there is a new dawn
with endless potential and her duty in
the cause of children around this
country is legendary secondly horses and
hounds on the countryside as a
countryman and an mp for a royal
constituency i want to thank her majesty
also her son and her grandsons for
always championing our rural heritage
and way of life from her love of the
wilds of her native scotland to the high
seas the skies of norfolk and her time
especially with her beloved horses and
hounds she was indeed the monarch of the
glenn
and may i say the fence
and
if the house will endorse my personal
note it's a great person of mine that a
love of racing and deep expertise in
thoroughbred racing my late father had
the great honor of being the retained
royal jockey to her late mother over
fences in the 50s and finally the unsung
heroes of voluntary service her late
majesty's commitment to the unsung
heroes of this country the charity
workers the community helpers those
selfless servants
embodied the spirit of selfless public
service that she always did let us take
this moment to renew our commitment to
them but let us also renew our
commitment to strive to renew fragile
public trust in our democracy her
majesty the queen took on the monarchy
in the wake of the abdication crisis and
the world war it's a remarkable and
unprecedented legacy that after 70 years
she leaves the monarchy stronger than
she found it and stronger perhaps than
it's ever been
god bless your majesty may she rest in
eternal peace
and may god save the king
rebecca long bailey thank you madam
deputy speaker on behalf of my
constituents in salford and eccles it's
an honor to pay tribute to her late
majesty the queen elizabeth ii and to
send our heartfelt condolences
love and prayers to her family the royal
household all who loved her and the
nation at this sad time
it's undeniable that she served us with
unrelenting duty dignity and kindness
her dedication to uniting us all was a
beacon of goodness through her long
reign and she never failed to lift us up
through the hard times and through the
good times
we've heard tonight that on her 21st
birthday as a princess she said
i declare before you that my whole life
whether it be long or short shall be
devoted to your service
and she never broke that promise
keeping her pledge with love and warmth
for over 75 years she really was a
shining example of the best of us
may she now rest in peace and may we
extend our love and support to his
majesty the king as he assumes his new
office at what can only be a period of
profound pain
god save the king
have to say
the reason for my hesitation is that
there are several people who i had
intended to call and i find that they're
not
present
which is most unfortunate
for them
most unfortunate for them there are four
people
i will tell them later
who they are
so instead
we'll go to hugh merriman
thank you madam deputy speaker and i
rise at this summer time to represent my
constituents in east sussex to send our
condolences to the royal family for
their deep loss of her late majesty the
queen east sussex was a county that her
majesty visited many times she helped to
commemorate the 900th year of the norman
invasion
visiting pevensey bay where william the
conqueror first landed and then going to
battle town where the battle of hastings
took place
for many we are not just mourning a
glorious reign of public service for the
last 70 years we're also mourning the
loss of the one
constant who have glued together our
past
and the present
this encapsulates the service of her
late majesty
she represented the historic traditions
of the past but she also sought to
champion and support the ideas of the
future and the generations to come and
perhaps i can use
her late majesty's link to transport in
this regard
there are many modes to which she is
to which she would be remembered
in land air and sea but i would like to
go
to the london underground
as a 13 year old
in 1939
then princess elizabeth joined her
sister princess margaret for her first
trip on the london underground according
to the network staff magazine penny fair
they reported both princesses were
greatly interested in the escalators
automatic ticket machines and automatic
doors
despite their status the
is sat in the third class smoking
carriage of the district line train
a further trip 30 years later on the
underground was to mark the opening of
the victoria line
there she operated the controls in the
cab of the first train on that line
going from
green park to oxford circus it being the
first tube line to be automatically
operated the queen could be said to be
its very first driver
the lake queen took the controls at the
front of the train on both the opening
of the piccadilly line extension and the
docklands light railway and only this
year we remember her with those amazing
photos as she was operating an oyster
card at the opening of the elizabeth
line
she truly was an innovator and always
interested in innovation
many in this chamber
and across the nation and the
commonwealth would not met have met
the late
majesty
that matters not
what matters is that we all remember and
keep apart
of us
celebrating her duty to public service
her graciousness her kindness
her devotion
and we don't just keep that with us
every day we demonstrate it and we
become better in her memory
may her late majesty rest in peace
god save the king
judith collins
madam deputy speaker i rise to speak
with great sadness to pay tribute to her
late majesty the queen on behalf of
myself
my constituents of bradford south
as our head of state for 70 years our
longest serving monarch with an
unrivaled sense of duty in serving her
people and it is that great sense of
dedication and devoted duty to her
people for which she's loved cherished
and remembered
her late majesty had a role in so many
defense that defined our lives both as
head of state and also as a symbol of
the values that we hold so dear as a
nation
her majesty was more than our queen she
was part of our everyday lives
visiting cities and towns across britain
the commonwealth and the world including
her five visits to bradford she was
woven into the very fabric of our
society
in my constituency the queen will be
remembered for representing the very
best of britain
she provided the glue that held the
nation together
through these difficult times providing
continuity and certainty to the nation
often through turbulent and changing
times
a queen for all people regardless of
faith or culture
the grandmother of a nation
a loving mother
grandmother and great-grandmother
a family and a nation mourns the passing
of a much loved admired and dedicated
public servant who was our queen
may she rest in peace god save the king
damian hines
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
on behalf of my constituents in east
hampshire i want to
convey our sincere sympathies to the
royal family and express our heartfelt
thanks
for the life of her late majesty my own
first consciousness of the queen like
many others who've spoken of roughly my
age was 1977. although unlike others
who've spoken i wasn't actually in the
same place as the queen at the time my
consciousness was just through the
street parties the bunting the mug which
by the way i still have and those little
if you remember them the little round
badges we got to sew onto our to our cub
uniform i didn't yet quite know how but
for the first time i got that sense that
as britons we are especially blessed
i could not have known possibly that
decades later i would have that rare uh
opportunity as others have mentioned to
meet uh to meet the queen and it was the
honour of my life to be admitted to the
privy council but most especially to be
able to attend one of those lunches at
windsor castle which have come up a few
times and have the opportunity to talk
directly with our monarch
about the subject which i was
representing which was education and i
have to say it was remarkable the level
not only of knowledge that she had about
current issues but also their level of
interest to discuss it further
a speaking of education i find when i
visit primary schools in east hampshire
actually were three questions that are
guaranteed from the kids the first is
what is your favorite color
the second is what's the prime minister
like and of course the third
is have you met the queen i love that
opportunity because i think it's
wonderful to talk to those children the
next generation
about her values and i always come away
taking a lot from it too we've heard
some some wonderful tributes today some
beautiful tributes actually to her late
majesty but i think probably the
biggest tribute of all that that any of
us
could make and i think particularly for
us in this place
is to seek to learn from
and to emulate her her example her
selflessness
her steadfastnessness
her commitment above all to service
her readiness to forgive
her appreciation of every individual
that she met
her valuing of custom and tradition
but equally her adaptability and
openness to change
madame deputy speaker our constitutional
monarchy is unique and special i found
myself last night trying to explain to
my own children exactly why
and how this family that
through no choice of their own carry a
great burden in the unity of nationhood
and a much much wider uh world role and
of course
with her passing that role carries on
the crown jaws
so we mourn our beloved queen elizabeth
and we celebrate too her life of service
eternal rest grant unto her her lords
and let perpetual light shine upon her
and may the lord bless and guide our
sovereign king charles god save the king
long may he reign
alan dorans
thank you madam dead speaker it is a
privilege for me to have the opportunity
to be able to express my sincere
personal sympathies and condolences and
those of my constituents in heir carrick
and komnak on the death of her majesty
the queen
the late queen will be remembered with
great affection especially for her
service
duty
humility humor and faith
our thoughts and prayers are with king
charles the third the queen concert and
the wider royal family at this sad time
madame dr speaker i met the lake queen
in 1973
when as a 17 year old police cadet
in the metropolitan police along with
others
i was invited to attend a royal garden
party in the grounds of buckingham
palace
her majesty chose to speak with me
probably because i was in uniform
as we all know how much she valued her
uniform services
her royal presence of smile
and gentleness left a lasting impression
on me
a few years later
when i was attested as a police
constable i took an oath of allegiance
which contained the words
i will well and truly serve the queen
in the office of constable
with fairness
integrity
diligence and impartiality
upholding fundamental human rights and
according equal respect to all people
madame dr speaker those words from me
encapsulate many of their values and
virtues and leadership qualities so
clearly displayed by the queen
throughout a long and illustrious reign
the oath also greatly influenced my
service as a police officer and i'm sure
many other generations of police
officers
in the feeling that every action i took
i was somehow acting personally
on behalf of the queen
for for the betterment and benefit of
our country
i am sure that everyone who has ever
served to the member of our armed
services
will also be able to read very closely
to that sentiment
and will as will anyone who has proudly
served in any capacity
in the name of the queen and all that
she stood for
my speaker it is with both sadness and
joy
that we celebrate the unparalleled
contribution the queen made in her 70
years as sovereign and recognized her
devotion to duty and the decades of
public service she gave to the people of
the united kingdom the commonwealth and
the world
one day speaker there is a distinct and
profound sense of loss on the death of
the queen throughout scotland
to where she is bound by close ties of
vandals and ancestry
affection and duty
her majesty has descended from the royal
house of stuart on both sides of her
family
and she has always held a very special
place in the hearts of people of
scotland
and i know her majesty also held a
similar affection for scotland its
culture and its people
madame dr speaker the next few weeks are
a time for reflection and remembrance
and to give thanks to god for the life
of an extraordinary individual the lake
of whom we will never see again
thank you your majesty if your life and
service god bless you and may your rest
eternal peace
thank you very much
richard drax
thank you madam deputy speaker
i stand here most humbly at the heart of
our democracy to represent my loyal
constituency of south dorset
and family and friends who don't have a
chance such as this to say farewell
now thank you to the queen for more than
70 years of service
the rich contributions at the house
today just show how she's touched every
single one of our lives it's absolutely
extraordinary
and if i may end the story about david
knott mentioned by the honourable member
for tooting and her touching speech
what she didn't say was because i know
david very well
the queen rang him four months later
and said because of the difficulty we
had last time
do come back and have lunch again
and he did
that is the
lady we are talking about
one such friend is admiral woodard the
last admiral to serve in the royal yacht
and who knew the queen extremely well
sadly he lies very ill in hospital
but i know that both he and his devoted
wife rosie want me to tell you
just what a kind remarkable and
beautiful woman the queen was
and how she will be sorely missed
none of us will forget what happens in
momentous events where we are
i was returning from birmingham for a
meeting with the defense committee where
we went again and see boeing
i felt like everyone in this house and
all the eloquent and excellent speeches
i've heard and millions across the world
an overwhelming
feeling of loss
it was personal we've heard that so many
times tonight
and shockingly real
i was fortunate enough to have the honor
to serve the queen for nine years in the
army
meeting her twice participating in her
unique birthday parade on two occasions
there was not a guardsman
that would not have followed the queen
to hell and back had she ordered it such
was the affection they had for her
and on that note allow me to tell you a
very short story
as i returned to wellington barracks one
morning i looked into the company office
and the company clark was sitting behind
his
typewriter
he was covered in bruises
it looked as if he'd run into a brick
wall at 90 miles an hour
i said to him what on earth happened to
you
in a dead pan voice the clerk explained
he'd taken his wife out to the pub
when three troublemakers entered
during the evening
these troublemakers picked a fight with
the couple and began to insult his wife
i intervened and i said i quite
understand i can understand i see what
happened he said no no sir you don't
understand
my wife and i could take that
but when they began to insult the queen
that's when i got stuck in
i gave him the day off
[Laughter]
of course it was not just the military
who adored her majesty the outpouring of
grief from every corner of the world is
testament to the level of respect and
affection her majesty was held
the queen has been an integral part of
my life and all our lives for so long
she has been the linchpin of our country
and her devotion to duty and country has
been so extraordinary that i suspect
many of us have taken her for granted
and like so many things we take for
granted it's not until we lose them that
we fully fully appreciate their value
and as i drove up today in the car i
couldn't help thinking that our party
reminds us all to hold dear to those we
love and to keep saying we love them
so on behalf of my constituents my
family my friends
rest in peace your majesty
god save the king
sarah james
thank you madam deputy speaker i rise on
behalf of my constituents of croydon
central to offer our condolences to the
family of the late queen elizabeth and
to offer our loyalty to the new king
queen elizabeth ii who reigned for 70
years was the only sovereign that most
of us have ever known
she was our constant in a changing world
our cornerstone at times of crisis and
our comfort when in sorrow
my nana was a big fan
my mum who's 70 this year remembers as a
child being read books about the young
princesses and looking at photos of them
all the time
i think the war years made that
generation feel particularly close to
the young queen
the queen was a friend to croydon she
visited many times in her reign
i remember precisely how exciting that
was
as a brownie lining up with my flag to
welcome her when she opened the queen's
gardens in the middle of my constituency
few things in my suburban childhood
topped a visit from the queen
of course it's not just croydon in this
country who are mourning the world is in
sorrow
the front page of the new york times
this morning simply says queen and
spirit of a nation
and many of us find it hard to imagine
britain without her
it feels bleak
but then i think what would she do
and what did she do when her own father
king george vi died and i know she would
stand tall face the day pray to her god
and do the best job she could
and as the king has said this evening
she would fearlessly embrace progress
and that is the spirit we all keep alive
heavy is the head that wears the crown
quite literally as it turns out she was
once heard to say that wearing a crown
is like wearing a 10 pound salmon on
your head
but she bore the weight well
her service her humility her constancy
is what we can all strive to achieve
the queen's death comes at a time of
real challenge for our country
if ever we needed to be more like her it
is now
so let one of her legacies be that we
will all try to be a little more like
her
service steady progress humility
constancy and some fun along the way
none of us will see another queen in our
lifetime
so we say thank you to her late majesty
and god save the king
thank you steve bryan
madam deputy speaker can i just concur
with what you said after listening to
our new sovereign king what a privilege
it was to sit here together in this
house of commons chamber and listen to
that address and
it gives a whole new expression to not a
dry eye in the house i thought he he put
it beautifully as always i just wanted
to say a few things on behalf of my
constituents in winster and charles ford
yesterday was of course
the saddest day imaginable of course we
all knew it was coming
for a while now i think we have known it
was it was coming not not least of
course after yesterday's
announcement from the palace commenting
on our late majesty's health which which
they they never do but the sense of
shock we all face today is of course
palpable and the sense of loss for our
great country and the commonwealth and i
too was at the commonwealth conference
in halifax nova scotia last month
is vast
this is a national moment of course but
as my honourable friend
speaking a couple of speakers ago said
it feels intensely personal and and it
is
her late majesty spoke very movingly of
her of her late husband the duke of
edinburgh as her strength of stay as my
honourable friend from cheltenham said
earlier but the truth was that she was
our strength and stay and that's why
we're going to miss her so greatly
i was extremely honored to meet
the late queen in 2012 as a relatively
new mp at buckingham palace and we all
lined up with our partners nervous as
you can possibly be
and those who were there will remember
that too but as so many almost every
speaker and i've sat through pretty much
every speech today
has said
nerves went and disappeared as soon as
they interacted with her majesty
so we needn't have worried
she asked me what constituency i
represent so i said winster of course
and we briefly discussed how the city
was still is
searching for the remains of king alfred
our most favorite son
the queen loved this and with that
trademark smile and much mentioned
twinkle in the eyes she said to me
they've just found one of my ancestors
under a car park in leicester
which was not which was not untrue
and she was of course referring to to uh
the remains of richard the third
our late queen visited winchester many
times including officially opening
elizabeth the second court
in 1959 the home of hampshire county
council and for the monday service in
april 1979 in our great cathedral which
has been the
the scene of several services today and
will be many more over the weekend and
it's the focal point of our county uh
and the diocese of course and we had the
new king in winchester just a few months
ago unveiling which is a mark of how i
think he will hold the crown wear the
crown unveiling a statue to a very
famous jewish figure in winchester
history called licoricia and it was a
pleasure to have him in winchester that
day
now i often remind my constituents that
mps back bench mps and maybe even some
on the front bench and i've been there
too don't really have that much power
but we do have quite a bit of influence
and the longer we do this job i think
the better we get at using that
influence for the benefit of our
constituents and our late queen of
course as a constitutional monarch
didn't hold any executive power in fact
she couldn't even vote but boy did she
wield great influence through her vast
experience which we've heard about from
her prime minister and her former prime
ministers her knowledge and the
commanding respect she had all over the
world there's been a lot of replaying
overnight of the words spoken by the
young princess elizabeth on her 21st
birthday
while in south africa the famous section
of that speech of course was whether my
life be long or short should be devoted
to the service of our imperial family
but she then went on to a lesser known
passage which said but i shall not have
the strength to carry out this
resolution alone unless you join in it
with me as i now invite you to do
and i've always been struck by that
comment as incredibly revealing and
brave because i think our then future
queen was saying i don't embody the
divine right of kings and queens so
fabled of course in british history i
have to earn it and i have to keep it i
need your support
and
i think she reigned in that spirit every
single day of her 70 years never lost in
the majesty of it all as some of her
very famous predecessors always knowing
that she had to draw that strength from
the support of her people and always
knowing that she had to constantly be
seen to be believed and maybe those two
famous appearances on the balcony of
buckingham palace either end of the
fabulous platinum jubilee weekend
earlier this summer showed that right
until almost the very end
she knew that she had to be seen to be
believed and i'm so glad that the
country and the world had those
incredible moments
we've heard a lot today just finally
madame dr speaker about school children
how they ask us if we've ever met the
queen and i get that too
but i had a school here
probably a decade ago when i was a
relatively new mp and as we were leaving
one of the school children said to me mr
brian can i just ask you a question i
didn't want to ask in front of all those
children and i said yes of course
and this young young lad said to me how
did god save the queen
and i still maintain it's the best
question i've ever been asked
and for those who want the answer was
that's one for your teachers
[Applause]
but maybe maybe our our late sovereign
lady now knows the answer to that as a
christian in this house i
believe everyone whether they live on
this planet a matter of hours
or 96 hugely influential years
as one of the most famous people ever to
walk the planet i think they change our
world by their presence in it
we are so so lucky as people have said
today to have had queen elizabeth ii in
our lives and we
are changed by it and will ever more be
so so thank you queen elizabeth ii it's
been a privilege and god save the king
toby perkins thank you very much madame
deputy speaker i rise to speak on behalf
of the people of chesterfield and
stavely who share the shock sadness and
pride at the passing of our beloved late
queen elizabeth ii
and to send our condolences to king
charles iii who spoke so well just a few
moments ago last night prayers at saint
michael's church in brimington were
dedicated to her late majesty and the
bells on the famous crooked spire will
be ringing muffled tones of mourning
books of condolence have already been
set up in chesterfield council's contact
center and others are appearing across
the borough as our town citizens come
out to send their respect and regards to
a truly remarkable woman who has
embodied our nation as harmonic for 70
years
i've we've heard from so many people
here who've had personal experience of
meeting her majesty but last night a
friend's son posted a video which has
gone viral of the moment that his
grandmother sat in the toby carvery
restaurant heard of the queen's passing
uncontrollably she sobs
in the background you can hear her son's
bewilderment but you never even knew her
mother
but the british people didn't have to
meet our queen
to feel that we knew her ought to feel
bereaved at her loss she was indeed a
friend to so very many of us
she's been the constant throughout our
lives at every celebration and grand
occasion naturally but more crucially in
times of peril worry and heartbreak it
was her majesty the queen that we looked
to
the queen promised on her coronation to
serve our nation faithfully and the
dedication wisdom and fortitude that
she's so shown throughout every day of
that service has inspired so many of us
she loved our country the four nations
that make up our united kingdom
individually and collectively and she
took great pride in the commonwealth as
she helped lead our nation through its
changing place in the world
from being the head of the british
empire to the commonwealth to a
prominent nation at the head of the eu
and subsequently into our post-brexit
future
she led us through two painful and
divisive referendums without ever
breaking her famous political
impartiality and she was there when our
nation was tortured by the cruel
pandemic
bringing us together as so many of us
sat there afraid and alone
an image that said so much about her
dedication to duty was the image of her
sat alone at her beloved husband's
funeral
no one would have begrudged her as being
sat with a family member but it was
typical that she would want the world to
see
that she was also subject to the same
restrictions so painfully being observed
by her people
in closing i'd like to say that we
should all remember that her late
majesty's family are grieving right now
yet forced at this most painful moment
to grieve in public
those organs of the press who believe
they are defending her majesty the queen
by attacking her children or her
grandchildren or claiming to know better
than they do how her family should
grieve do our nation and our royal
family a huge disservice
the people of chesterfield will always
take pride in her selfless devotion and
wish her his majesty king charles iii a
long happy and successful reign god save
the king yeah yeah
rebecca paul
and i'm absolutely honored to be able to
pay tribute for the remarkable life of
her majesty who has touched all of our
hearts in so many ways bringing comfort
and guidance
to all of us whenever it is needed
now queen elizabeth ii holds a very
special place in the hearts of the
people of taunton dean my constituency
because she made a visit in 1987 and it
was the first visit by a monarch for
almost
500 years
since
the monmouth rebellion
and the infamous battle of sejmore
where
the royals were almost overthrown and
the monarchy
now it's a well-known story in my
constituency that queen victoria was
passing
down through the west country on the
train heading to devon and when she was
passing through taunton she asked for
all the blinds to be put down
because she didn't want to see
rebellious taunton
and that was following the monmouth
rebellion which was absolutely years
before
and the train stopped in taunton and a
civil party was waiting for her but she
refused to alight
now many many years later this incident
was related to the duke of edinburgh and
he was absolutely furious so of course
he shared the story with her majesty the
queen and she determined to set the
record straight and that's why in 1987
she made that visit to taunton and we
still thank her for it we're back in the
good books hopefully that can happen to
the rest of us
similar things going on in this place
i think it demonstrates doesn't it
just that power that her majesty had how
she always wanted to set the record
straight to be fair and i'm delighted
that since then she's made other visits
to um taunton and to somerset
i just wanted to recount a very small um
personal story about her majesty now i
can't lay claim to any of these bowings
and going to going to buckingham palace
with all the big um
titles that one may get in this place
although the stories have been
absolutely brilliant that we've heard
um it was back a very long time ago in
1985 i was working for the national
farmers union in taunton and i ran an
organization called the taste of
somerset which was all sorts of small
independent food and drink producers
belonged to it it was the first such
initiative in the country and i had to
set up a big marquee for the taste of
somerset running at the royal bathroom a
show
of which her majesty was a patron and i
then was given the honor of presenting
her with a taste of sunset hamper
and i was absolutely beside myself with
nerves as so many colleagues have said
you know when you think you're going to
meet the queen i'd had the outfit made
it had the hair done practice the curtsy
and i was beside myself
but anyway along she came and she was
utterly charming and delightful and all
she had to do was that smile
and she made me feel so comfortable i
forgot all my nerves and we've still got
that photograph my mother has on the
mantelpiece on the sideboard at home of
the beautiful
smile
and and the handing over the basket now
beside that picture on my mother's
sideboard is a picture of prince charles
with my walking through the family farm
at home because it was a dutchy farm on
which i grew up and that's a treasured
photograph on our sideboard as well and
i remember that day so well we were all
invited walking across the farm talking
about trees cows the countryside
everything prince charles was so
passionate about and the remarkable
thing i also remember about the event
was we had lunch together and he ate my
pudding
and i would tell this story because
beside that letter right now
that photograph is a letter that prince
charles himself
uh now the king sent to my mother just
at the beginning of this week
and it was a letter and he was then
prince charles to my mother uh
giving condolences for my dear father
the farmer who died and we buried him
last week
and it was the most wonderful personal
emotional letter remembering all the
visits to the farm that you could ever
wish for and that's the mark of the man
and how sad madam deputy speaker that
now the tables in literally three days
have turned and now we are offering our
condolences to the prince charles who is
now our wonderful king and i'd like to
give those deepest concerns condolences
from the people of taunton dean
now just briefly her majesty of course
has been a cornerstone in all of our
lives head of state for 70 years
presiding over us through all of our ups
and downs and everybody across this
house and even outsiders just use the
list of words that i think none of us
can disagree with
the epitome of goodness steadfast
honorable warm humorous strong
engaging understanding
inspirational most of all inspirational
i think madam deputy speaker degree for
women
and
i just want to say thank you
thank you
thank you
how fortunate we are to have lived with
this person head of our state and
she passes on so many of the attributes
to king charles iii he treads in giant
footsteps even though her majesty had
tiny feet
but i know that he is going to in his
own unique way take the nation and the
commonwealth forward in an exceptional
way just as his own mother the late
queen did
so may her blessed majesty rest in peace
and god save the king
order
we're going to sit till around 10
o'clock this evening so that's another
two and a half
hours
um
even
if everyone who is here takes just under
three minutes not everyone who has
expressed a desire to speak this evening
will have an opportunity to do so
um
the remedy
rests with you
mr speaker asked and madam deputy
speaker asked earlier if people could
please keep their contributions to under
three minutes now
contributions have crept up to well over
three minutes
um
i might gently hint
that
there's no need now
to repeat the things that have already
been said
122 times
there are many
emotions which we are all feeling and
they have already been
expressed
so i make a plea to everyone who is now
going to speak have a look at the notes
you have
cut them in half
and
you will be loved by your colleagues
always remembering that brevity is the
soul of wit
chiomura
thank you madam deputy speaker the
people of newcastle have always held a
strong and proud sense of our own
identity as geordies as working people
as citizens of the united kingdom and
for seven decades as subjects of her
majesty queen elizabeth her death leaves
us bereft in ways we cannot fully
comprehend
queen elizabeth cared about the things
that we geordies care about she was like
so many geordies a veteran of our armed
forces devoted to our service men and
women i am proud that the queen's own
humanery is headquartered in my
constituency the queen loved her sport
as we do and we remember with great
affection when she presented newcastle
united with our last fa cup trophy in
1955
we look forward to king charles iii
making a similar presentation in the
near future
i never met her
late majesty like the majority of my
constituents but her presence graced our
city she first came to newcastle central
in 1954 a day she said she would never
forget i remember when she opened eldon
square in 1977 in our metro in 1981 and
i regularly look upon the plaque
commemorating her opening of our
beautiful city library
as head of state queen elizabeth was a
profoundly important global figure she
could have tried to retain the imperial
aura of the monarchy's past all faded
into the background as a distant symbol
instead she found a way to be a constant
stability for our parliamentary
democracy a forceful presence reassuring
us that our unwritten constitution had a
human embodiment
beyond those of us who sit for a time
here in westminster and that shouldn't
come to it our ancient liberties and our
modern rights had a formidable guardian
for me personally i can say that when i
heard the news i was disoriented in all
of her service and unable to understand
my country without her but i also
thought of when as a young woman in the
1980s i was devoted to the cause of
ending apartheid in south africa at a
time when many british institutions
would entangled with that evil in a way
which made me doubt whether i belonged
in the country of my birth
the queen stood in solidarity with the
commonwealth in the face of apartheid
south africa her love for the
commonwealth as a community of equals
her fundamental understanding that
racism and fascism are evil insured
esteem from newcastle central to
newcastle kwazulu across our
commonwealth
but i end where i started in newcastle
her platinum jubilee celebrated with
enthusiasm in our leafy avenues and less
cared for council estates i remember
particularly a tea party in holly court
retirement home blake law the love
respect enthusiasm and laughter we
shared that afternoon in the queen's
honor was so sincere so genuine and made
all the more poignant because the
organizer mrs t had just received a
british empire medal for services of the
community and was so so proud
we miss the queen we are grateful to her
and we say god save the king
alex berghardt
thank you uh madam deputy speaker it's a
real honour to be called in this debate
on a day in which there have been so
many moving contributions from both
sides of the house indeed i can't help
but feeling that once again her late
majesty has brought out the best in all
of us
i it's also a real honor to be uh
representing my constituents of
brentwood and anger in essex there may
be more fervent royalists out there
madam deputy speaker they are not to be
found on this earth the uh
i i've been thinking over the past 24
hours of um of my great grandmother
uh who lived with me when i was growing
up
uh because uh the feelings i'm
experiencing are similar to those that i
experienced when she died
uh it's um it's a strange sensation
because
it reminds you that family
is not limited to blood
it's not limited to the people you know
people you've met indeed one of the
powerful things about the chemistry of
nationhood is that it gives you deep
affection for and deep loyalty to
people you've never met
people you will never meet
and this is true
both
across the nation as it is today but
across the nation through time
this is something that her majesty and
her 70 years on the throne her 96 years
of life
really embodied
you see
she connected us not just with one
previous generation but with many
she had known
her grandfather george v
who had known his grandmother queen
victoria
who as an infant had met george iii
and george iii had spent his youth
surrounded by people involved in the
glorious revolution of 1688
and so it is within four conversations
that the whole
modern scope
of our constitutional monarchy
was brought together
four pecks on the cheek that brings
those generations to one point
we can take things further
you see today is the 935th anniversary
of the death of william the conqueror in
1087 so i'm sure the house as well
and um
when one thinks
that her life
her late majesty's life encompassed more
than one tenth of that time
it makes you realize how close the
centuries are when we think of our union
the great union between england and
scotland 315 years old this year
22 of that time saw her on the throne
she was not just a witness to history
she was a part of it
she left it to us
as
her legacy
a nation may chase after its past madame
deputy speaker but it will not catch it
what it can hope to do
is imitate it and use its strengths to
fight the monsters of today and the
future
this her late majesty knew
this we will do in her memory god save
the queen
carolyn harris thank you madam deputy
speaker and as we collectively mourn the
loss of our queen elizabeth ii i join
others in sending my prayers and
condolences and those of my constituents
to the king the queen consort and the
whole of the royal family and as deputy
leader of the welsh labour party i send
our condolences to all of the royal
family
we all have our own memories of the
queen minds stretch back to the 1960s
but as a young child i stood outside my
primary school in brahmarad to watch her
car drive past i can't quite remember
the purpose of a visit but i do remember
the buzz of excitement amongst my
classmates and how honored we felt to
just catch a glimpse of her
and i also remember the honor of
receiving an invite to the queen's
garden party years before i entered this
place i was heavily pregnant at the time
and had no interest at all and going
anywhere but i wasn't going to miss the
opportunity to be part of something so
special as her majesty's garden party
because she was special
her dedicated service for more than 70
years will be remembered forever she
served our country with loyalty with
dignity and with grace and even as her
health began to fail in recent years her
commitment never faltered
she would be missed immeasurably by this
country the commonwealth and indeed
across the world but nowhere more so
than amongst her own family and our
thoughts remain with them foremost at
this time
it was an honor to see her as a little
girl it was an honor to be invited to
the garden party
and it's my greatest honor
to pay tribute to hope today on behalf
of the communities across swan's east
she served us well and it's as honduras
sleep
rest in peace our queen
god save the king and god bless the new
prince and princess of wills
[Music]
thank you madam deputy speaker
it's with the deepest sadness that i
write to speak on behalf of the people's
error wash to pay tribute to our late
sovereign majesty queen elizabeth ii
in an era of unprecedented change her
majesty has been a constant beacon of
strength and stability
whose sense of duty and public service
remained until the very last moment of
her
life while today britain mourns the
passing of our head of state you must
first and foremost remember that the
king and his family have lost their
beloved mother grandmother and
great-grandmother
a sense of grief and sorrow that will be
familiar to all of us who have lost
loved ones
i therefore want to wish
to extend my sincere and heartfelt
condolences to the king and the whole
royal family at this sad time
it's estimated that around one third of
the country has either met or seen the
queen during her reign
it's fair to say that she'll have
touched each and every one of us in some
way or another
for me personally i'm experienced
immensely proud to achieve the queen's
guide award
i know the values i learned on route
that award helps me to serve as a member
of parliament today
as a woman born in the first decade of
the queen's reign i like so many others
view her majesty as an icon and a role
model
not only a beautiful lady in mind and
spirit but also someone who approached
the heavy burden of the crown with grace
and good humor in order to serve us her
people
perhaps aided by one or two marmalade
sandwiches at times
although not originally destined to
ascend to the throne
in 1952 our new queen set out as one of
the few married working mothers and
certainly the only female head of state
of any major western power
seven decades later
and following her majesty's example
women have firmly cemented their
position in the workplace
represented every sector from
construction to government
and perhaps the most poignant reminder
of which was the appointment of my
writing my friend as the queen's third
female prime minister just four days ago
now as the second elizabethan age draws
to a close our new caroline era begins
our country the commonwealth and its
people stand ready for whatever
challenges may lie ahead
better prepared for having been led by
her majesty for over 70 years i united
behind our new sovereign king charles
iii
god save the king
stella christie
thank you madam deputy speaker we've
heard some glorious stories today about
gin
cheese fiddling with wands and what it
was like to work with the queen
but as i came into this place today and
saw the trains full of people carrying
flowers on their way to green park it
struck me for most people it was just
the queen herself not to work with her
that was inspiring
and i saw that when she came to
walthamstow during the diamond jubilee
the civic pride was evident
not least because we felt we'd won the
competition with other nearby boroughs
because we were going to get to feed her
even the most cynical uncertainty about
royalty or put off by pomp could not
help but bask in the glorious sunshine
and the joy that came that day
indeed as she was driven round the
fountain to the cheers
of the school children the queen later
told our late council leader chris
robbins that the noise was deafening and
like a pop concert after all she sat
there enough to know what they sounded
like
it was surreal that day but it embodied
that sense of excitement than awe that
we all felt when we were finally able to
pass that mp right of passage have you
met the queen and look the school
children in our communities in the eye
i have no doubt that king charles will
face the same set of questions
and that interest was returned it was so
clear to me that day that what she cared
about was not the pomp of the
politicians or the officials but the
people that she got to meet so it is
only fitting in paying tribute to her on
behalf of the people of walthamstow that
i use their words
from the borough commander simon crick
who speaks on behalf of our local police
and how for them she was a constant
reassuring presence in an often
turbulent world
or our local council leader grace
williams who remembers her devotion and
service to our country the commonwealth
and our people in a time of
extraordinary change
or dr ken aswany who speaks on behalf of
our local nhs that she will remain a
source of energy to many of us in the
years to come to enable us to move
forward together
or libby a local volunteer who was born
in 1953 and therefore named after the
queen and can honestly say she is so
proud to have been named after this
incredible woman
or donna who said she carried herself so
elegantly yet felt like everyone's
grandma at the same time
i represent a community with links
across the world so many of them
reference that martin who says that her
visit to ireland standing up and opening
her speech in irish was a stunning
moment and her contribution to peace
cannot be understated
he wanted to write more but he could not
just find the words
or pastor anthony who records his
appreciation for her work in the
commonwealth and defense of religious
freedom around the world
daughter a dual danish and british
citizen who said that during the
pandemic she sent a ray of hope
believing that one day we would see each
other again
or philip who reflects how she book
ended his life
seeing those poster stamps change and
watching a tv for the first time to see
her coronation and now her passing
and that general sense of how as we
contemplate life without her sparkle and
without her cheer to bring us together
that people from all walks of life in
communities like mine were inspired by
her
let us put on record our thanks to to
those people in the coming days who will
help us commemorate her the police the
officials the volunteers who will help
us in the days ahead
one queen beloved
one king with well wishes all of us
brought together all of us in mourning
god save the king
just before i call uh the next colleague
i'd like to briefly make my own tribute
on behalf of the people of epping forest
whose voice will otherwise be unheard
simply to say
that her majesty
was held so dear
in all our hearts for her kindness her
cleverness her dedication and her grace
and that
as a role model for women of future
generations
she was unsurpassed
we have all been so fortunate
to live and to serve
during her reign
eddie hughes
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
and i rise to speak on behalf of the
good people of willing or blocks rich
and warsaw north and curiously also on
behalf of the good people of tombridge
and maling because their excellent mp
will be unable to speak this evening as
he's sat comfortably on the front bench
but we will be united in our thoughts
conveying our strongest condolences
to his majesty the king at this time of
intense sorrow for him his family and
for the entire country however madam
deputy speaker i make no apology for the
fact that i'm going to be slightly more
upbeat with the rest of my contribution
because we are after all celebrating
an incredible life as the king himself
said this evening well lived wherever
she went
the queen spread joy and happiness and
that was reflected back to her and so it
is that that joy and happiness was also
spread i'm delighted to say to warsaw in
1962 she came to visit a big local
employer in warsaw crabtree electricals
and then from there she headed over to
willenhall one of the towns in my
constituency i'm delighted to say she
must have enjoyed it because she came
back again in 1977 on the silver jubilee
tour she visited warsaw and then headed
off to block switch another one of the
towns in my constituency
she hadn't had enough though she came
back again
in 2000 for the opening of our iconic
art gallery now i have to say madame
deputy speaker i was slightly distracted
on this occasion because my friend simon
was her close protection officer on that
day so as we toured the gallery i was
very slightly distracted by the fact
that he had a gun in his pocket
now i'm delighted to say
the visit passed off without incident
and we sent her majesty safely on her
way
it was lovely to have her there but that
doesn't end
warsaw's association with her majesty
because
and i'm seeking to
address an omission in a number of
contributions this evening because we've
all talked about how lovely her humorous
double act was with paddington but it
seems to me that nobody has referred to
the fact that that handbag from which
she withdrew that marmalade sandwich was
made in warsaw
madame deputy speaker the affiliation
that we feel in warsaw and right across
the country is incredibly incredibly
warm we will all miss her may perpetual
light shine upon her and may she rest in
peace
god save the king
emma hardy
thank you madam deputy speaker and it is
an honor to pay tribute to queen
elizabeth on behalf of myself and the
constituents of whole western health and
hazel and it is with deep sadness i make
my contribution because you could see
how loved the queen was actually in the
whole western hustle you can see this on
the day of the jubilee celebrations when
we have the very youngest people out
there celebrating babies and prams and
mums enjoying themselves right the way
up to our older residents as well
celebrating the reign of the queen and
on the way down today on the train i
spoke to my mum and she said to me that
she was feeling really unsettled and
she'd been a bit upset
and she's never met the queen to be
honest i've never met the queen either
but the fact that my mum was feeling
unsettled by her death i think
illustrates what a constant she has been
in each and all of our lives how she's
been relied on and and my mum said to me
she says emma she went i was one and a
half when the queen came in it's all
i've ever known and through everything
that my mom has lived through in her
life there's always been the queen and
she said i almost felt that she'd always
be there and we know now of course no
one can always
be there and her passing has touched us
all
in whole western hazel in the uk in the
commonwealth but i'm very pleased to see
internationally as well i truly believe
that having the queen as our head of
state has enhanced our reputation as a
country just look at those front covers
around the world look at the tributes
coming in from world leaders whatever
world leader would have the number of
tributes and the real adoration that our
queen had
you could rely on her you knew if we
were sending the queen to go and meet
other dignitaries around the world you
knew it was going to go well and you
knew it was going to make our country
look good and that gives you that sense
of real pride and that came from her
and what she did
so she was our queen but she was of
course as many have said the royal
family's mum their grandma and their
great grandma so god bless the queen as
she is now reunited with her beloved
husband
and god bless king charles the third
roman christian
thank you madam deputy speaker
my thoughts and those of chillingham and
radium are with his majesty king charles
iii and the rest of the royal family
madam deputy speaker i refer
to a prayer from saint john henry newman
a great british saint with global impact
and for me it was a real privilege and
an honor to be part of a delegation led
by his royal highness prince of wales in
2019 for the canonization of john henry
newman representing the prime minister
as his special envoy for freedom of
religion or belief
the prayer which i
wish to share with colleagues today
by john henry newman is this
the mission of my life
god has created me to do him some
definitive service
her majesty's selfless commitment
to public service
is an example to us all
of definitive service
he has committed some work to me which
he has not allocated to another
my god he gave her majesty all our work
she did it with complete distinction and
commitment with grace
always giving without any expectation of
any return
goes on to say i have my mission
i may never know it
in this life but i shall be told in the
next
i am a link
in a chain
a bond of connection between persons
her majesty
was most certainly an amazing link that
brought us all together
from all parts of the united kingdom
from all parts of the commonwealth from
all parts of the world from all faiths
and none based on her values of kindness
of compassion of respect of acceptance
of one another
john henry newman goes on to say
he has created me from not i shall do
good
her her majesty certainly did that
i shall do this work i shall do his work
i should be an angel of peace a preacher
of truth in my own place whilst not
intending if i do but keep his
commandments her majesty was most
certainly an angel of peace and a
preacher of truth your majesty
thank you from the bottom of our hearts
your values what you stood for will
forever live on
and our inspiration for us all
and i say this there could be no one
finer than his royal highness the
principals now king charles iii to take
our great country forward with his
values and what he stands for one thing
which has not been mentioned so far
for decades
decades
his majesty king charles iii has been
committed to interfaith dialogue he has
been committed to bringing people
together for faith and none eighty
percent of our world has one faith on
the other and if you have somebody like
his majesty
king charles iii committed to bringing
people together and people know his
commitment to interfaith then i know our
world can be brought together for the
common good by him
god save the king
liz twist
thank you madam deputy speaker and i
rise this evening to pay tribute to her
late majesty queen elizabeth ii on
behalf of myself and my constituents in
bladen
my memories of the queen will be shared
by so many people
i remember pouring over those royal
photo books that my aunties had showing
her work during and after the war years
they meant so much to them my mum just
three years younger than her majesty and
her sisters not much different
i was so pleased to hear a few weeks ago
that my youngest aunt still has the
books
lining the street as a school child
enthusiastically waving a flag at the
royal car as it drove past and the huge
anticipation of that fleeting glimpse
seeing her majesty from a distance or on
tv at those great state occasions over
so many years
so many of us will have personal
memories from across the 70 years of her
reign and just recently i had the real
pleasure of joining so many of my
constituents young and not so young
celebrating her platinum jubilee
starting the weekend with a jubilee
breakfast in kibblesworth instructed in
advance to wear red white and blue
lighting the jubilee beacon at the land
of okinawan heritage center in wind
layton mill
in the rain
being waited on by our young carers
group in highfield for lunch in the
sunshine with flags and bunting
taking part in the jubilee picnic in
crow crook in the sunshine so many loyal
toasts and celebrations to mark her
majesty's 70 incredible years and to
thank her for her service
her majesty was no stranger to the north
east
visiting as often and she was always
welcome and now i think of her personal
connection with blade and constituency
through her mother through the national
trust give side estate and the bulls
lion family connections
madam deputy speaker i don't have those
wonderful personal stories of queen
elizabeth to share but like so many of
my constituents i know the tremendous
regard in which her majesty was held and
the impact she had on the life of our
communities
the high esteem and affection in which
she was held by so many of us for her
dedication sense of duty and her
willingness to join in to be part of our
occasions whether it was the james bond
helicopter flight at the olympics or
taking t with paddington for the
platinum jubilee so i say thank you your
majesty for your steadfastness and work
over 70 years and may you now rest in
peace
duncan baker
thank you madam deputy speaker on behalf
of my constituents in north norfolk i
rise to pay our respects on the 70-year
reign of our sovereign queen elizabeth
ii
we've been asked not to repeat other
stories that have been told by other
members and so i think i want fairly
safe ground to be able to talk about
carrots coconuts and her majesty all in
the same speech
of course norfolk has a very special and
enduring memory for her majesty thanks
to sandringham
located just outside my constituency to
the west of the county and in my
friends the honourable member for north
west norfolk
although i've never met the queen myself
i share with you a simple anecdote and
story
which involves sandringham her majesty
and one that i was involved in many
years ago
it provides i think a wonderful insight
into the personal character and a
touching human story of a remarkable and
wonderful lady behind the scenes
as many back home know my family
business uh was run from halt
famed for many royal visitors across the
years and we ran the town's supermarket
we were supplied with vegetables by a
company which very proudly had a royal
crest for doing so
now this story involves christmas and
why our supplier was late one year with
the christmas vegetable delivery
you can imagine the scene can't you the
good burgers of my constituency lined up
to get their carrots and uh their
coconuts and of course their brussels
sprouts all looking a little bit frantic
on christmas eve morning when the
vegetable delivery had failed to turn up
when it of course did eventually turn up
a rather stressful delivery driver who
was also the owner uh relayed at length
how tired he was because he had
personally been up all night scrubbing
the queen's vegetables ready for that
royal household delivery but he had done
one huge mistake
he had forgotten the queen's very
special order
and he had to turn around to go back and
get it himself
well as a little upstart of course i had
to know what this special delivery was
and he said well
every year
the queen asks us to put on side
ten
carrots
and two coconuts
halved
drilled
and hung with some string
well of course i looked rather quizzical
at this i wondered how the royal family
would share two coconuts all around the
table for their christmas lunch and eat
it from a piece of string with the husk
still around it
but of course i was told that of course
what the queen likes to do
is on the cold crisp morning of
christmas day itself she steps out from
her bedroom into her private garden to
hang the coconut on a tree to then
retire to her bedroom to watch the birds
eat the coconut herself
and then i said what about these carrots
oh yes he said they have to be
particularly particularly of a certain
size
absolutely cylindrical so that they fit
into the queen's jacket
now i thought what is going on with this
well of course he said it's her special
treat
to the royal ponies
every single christmas morning it's her
treat traditionally to feed them with
those carrots
so there was this man from norfolk up
all night scrubbing the queens to
carrots little did he know they were for
the royal ponies
i think that story just shows the human
touching and
loving side of the queen who not only
loved her family and nation but also
her animals
her majesty the queen dedicated her life
to service of others she was example to
us all and will be remembered eternally
god save the king
evans
thank you madam deputy speaker
in a world which is often confusing and
unsettled
her majesty queen elizabeth ii
charted a course through stormy weather
not simply as the mother of our nation
but as the keeper of the flame
in the darkest of times when hope was
seemingly lost
she cut a reassuring figure
in 1966 when a landslide smashed into
pant glass junior school in havan
killing six
116 children and 28 adults
she visited the village
and openly wept
before she too was a young mother
51 years later in 2017 after a terror
attack in manchester at an ariana grande
concert in manchester the queen provided
comfort to the survivors and families
visit them all in hospital
during lockdown where many of us were
missing our loved ones she moved the
nation to tears with a simple message
we will meet again
in doing so she gave us all hope that in
the end it was all going to be all right
all of us want to be reassured that
whatever we are doing
whatever we feel whatever we're going
through
it's going to be all right in the end
but now with her passing it feels it's
going to be a long time before it's all
right again
madam deputy speaker historians often
cite powerful monarchs like henry viii
who ruled the country with an iron fist
or his father henry vii
who took the crown on the battlefield or
his daughter elizabeth the first who saw
the most powerful navy ever assembled in
the form of the spanish armada
our queen
simply give a heart to this nation for
70 years
proving beyond doubt love is a far more
powerful weapon
than any used in any war
her passing is another loss to the
generation lived through the depression
of the 1930s
so the rise of fascism in europe i knew
the horrors and hardships of war
then without complaint
rolled up their sleeves and got to work
rebuilding this bomb damage country
the work of the queen
and millions like her during those years
means we can enjoy the freedoms we do
today
when we came together to celebrate her
70th jubilee in june
we all knew in our heart of hearts the
long reign was drawn to a close
but we all hoped we would have a few
more years with that glorious smile of
hers
there are those of us who thought
somewhat irrationally she really was
immortal
and for as long as the queen was in our
world
everything was going to be all right
now she belongs to the ages
in times of sadness man and deputy
speaker i've always found great comfort
in the words of alfred lord tennyson who
wrote in the poem ulysses
we are not now that strength which in
all days moved ev
earth and heaven
that which we are we are
one equal temper heroic hearts
made weak by time and fate but strong in
will
to strive to seek and not to yield
as the elizabethan era draws to a close
let those words guide us and our new
monarch king charles iii in all the hard
days ahead
as we grieve as a nation
let us celebrate the life
of the queen elizabeth ii and draw
comfort in the knowledge
she is safe in the hands of almighty god
god save the king and god bless the new
prince and princess of wales
[Applause]
thank you very much
it's an honor to follow such an
inspiring speech by the honourable
member and i speak on behalf of myself
and my constituents in devises and
particularly of the many members serving
and former of the humanities armed
forces who served under her colours and
swore their oath to
president de gaulle said that he had a
certain idea of france
we have no need of such abstractions
we don't need an idea of the united
kingdom we have had for 70 years an
actual
person who represented the best of our
country and its character
and others have spoken of the character
of the late queen and not knowing her i
i can't add anything to that those
primary school visits are an absolute
agony uh for me i just go from one clash
into another disappointing the children
have not
met the queen
but i want to talk briefly about about
what she stood for and phillip larkin's
poem has been quoted often
today with this perfect line she did not
change
she did not change even as we did
and as we've heard she presided over the
most extraordinary period of change
and yet she was emphatically not a relic
of the past we loved her and valued her
because she was a conduit of something
precious from the present to the future
and the member for birmingham yardley
said earlier that we can find what we
want in a queen whether a modernist or a
traditionalist and of course we find
both
in her and this is the real value of
tradition not because it fossilizes the
past a real traditionalist as someone
said is someone who tends the flame of
their culture not someone who worships
its ashes
and those of us with conservative
instincts need to remember that
the queen was a great futurist as well
as the duke of edinburgh of course
uh but as the honourable member for
southwest devon said and others have
made the same point if modern britain
was founded on the rock of queen
elizabeth that is because her life was
founded on the rock of ages on her
christian faith
and i read today that as the country
became more secular in recent decades
she became more publicly religious and i
think it's worth noting that while she
dedicated her long life to the service
of the people
she held herself accountable not to us
but to a higher power and this was the
source of her joy and her goodness
and so my sympathy to her family to her
friends and her household in their grief
and my thanks to her and she is doing in
depth what she did in life bringing us
together making us smile reminding us of
the things that really matter making us
proud of our country and grateful for
her example and her service may she rest
in
where peace he durfield
thank you madam deputy deputy speaker
we've heard so many incredibly moving
and unforgettable speeches today about
our late majesty and we'll certainly
hear many more
it's of course impossible to pay full
tribute to 70 years of continuous public
service in just a few minutes so i wish
to focus briefly on canterbury the heart
of the church of england we've had the
honor of welcoming her majesty to
canterbury cathedral on numerous
occasions in her role as supreme
governor of the church of england
where she is well represented
on all occasions by her lord lieutenant
of kent
and it is in that light that i share the
tribute paid by justin archbishop of
canterbury who said through times of war
and hardship through seasons of upheaval
and change and through moments of joy
and celebration
we have been sustained by her late
majesty's faith in what and who we are
called to be
in march 2015 her majesty the queen
visited the cathedral accompanied by her
husband to unveil statues of them both
although the memories of her late
majesty will live on in the hearts and
minds of all of us it's those physical
tributes which will retain her legacy
for generations to come
no matter one's political persuasion
occupation way of life she commanded
respect from people of all backgrounds
and was an inspiration to women the
world over
she focused on the good things in life
the characteristics and experiences
which unite us as well as the issues
which need to be tackled in a collegiate
fashion
and some of us here can relate well to
that apparent rebellious streak we saw
when she left the palace and walked
among the crowds with her sister or
drove herself around in her land rover
that humour and wit which allowed us to
relate to the greatest diplomat in our
recent history the stability that
allowed us as a country to have
certainty at times when it was
desperately needed
the remarkable thing about her majesty
was that this was never a burden to her
her tremendous experience allowed her to
guide the united kingdom the
commonwealth and also the world through
tough times and her dutiful actions
the messages she conveyed to us have
undoubtedly made this world a much
better place
so rest in peace your majesty the nation
will never forget our favorite grandma
and god save the king
mckinley
deputy speaker it is a true honor to be
able to be
here at this time in our nation's
history and to be able to speak my
sorrow
and the great grief from my constituents
of south vanet through my words
yesterday
was a day we all knew would come
but i think we all hoped that it never
would
we're all trusting that that that huge
longevity of uh
the queen mother who died at 101 would
give us more years
of the queen in her place
giving her powerful and steady service
to our country
and to her realms overseas in the
commonwealth more years of certainty and
calm
but as that day developed yesterday i
will never forget from mid-afternoon i
felt a deep sadness
and with that emotion overflowing i will
tell you as that official announcement
came out at about half past six and i
asked myself
why
a 96 year old
a life well lived
dying peacefully
in a home that she loved surrounded by
family
why did i have this emotion this love
for a person i'd never
met
there were few in this house that would
have met her properly apart from prime
ministers most interactions have been
brief and fleeting
uh moments that everybody cherishes
with that most remarkable lady i was
saddened
because she'd been ingrained in my life
in all of our lives
she was that true and reliable person
that this country had grown to rely upon
all of our lives we'd grown up
knowing that every day when we looked at
banknotes coins
and stamps
that image
had been replicated literally hundreds
of billions of times in this country in
our overseas realms
and the commonwealth
we knew her on a daily basis
now across those
70 years
this remarkable woman had seen new
nations formed she'd seen empires
collapsed she'd seen governments here
and abroad come and go
and she'd met most of those characters
involved
and at times of this nation's great
crisis
and great joy it was to her that we that
we looked
a madam deputy speaker consider this her
first prime minister that she called
upon
to form a government was winston
churchill who was born in 1874
her last prime minister our current
prime minister was born in 1975 a period
of over a hundred years
that's quite staggering and she was on
the throne for close to 30 percent of
the entire existence of the united
states
quite staggering those changes that she
lived through
and yet she adapted seamlessly to each
and every one
she was the rock
that we thought would stand
forever
she was our head of state she was the
queen in many other realms and dominions
and head of the commonwealth she was
more than that she was i feel the true
matriarch of the world
and i think we're seeing that in the
grief and the tributes that were being
seen
across virtually every country in the
world today
and there is no part of this united
kingdom no constituency that she didn't
touch with either a visit
or a patronage and i know in my patch in
south planet people still talk about
that visit to ramsgate in 1993
and to margate in 2011.
but it's at times like this we see our
constitution
in play all roads of that continuity
the community government our armed
services uh police and justice had led
to her
and now we see a smooth transfer of the
crown to her dear son
she managed to keep the magic
and mystery of monarchy whilst being
taken into our hearts of our country
everybody around the world
and in
our dear majesty's words after 9 11. she
said
grief is the price we pay for love
we grieve now
and we look to a new era
under charles iii
rest in peace your majesty
thank you for your service
and god save the king
and you need to remind colleagues again
that the speaker has asked if um
remarks could be confined to three
minutes because if they're five minutes
it means that somebody else isn't going
to get in so i think it's important that
we think of others christine jardine
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
and it is with
a very sad sense of pride that i rise to
speak on behalf of my constituents in
edinburgh west many of whom i already
know have visited the palace of
hollywood house today to leave flowers
and pay their respects to her majesty in
edinburgh a city she loved
and was at one of my first very first
events as an mp when she opened our
magnificent queensferry crossing
um
and
most recently was celebrated in jubilee
parties across the city
but i confess madame deputy speaker
speaker my first thought when i had the
confirmation on thursday that we had
lost her was a family first her family
of course
but then in my own family my grandmother
who i remember as a child when i was
going to my first sighting of the queen
at the launch of a ship from the and
clydeside she told me how wonderful the
queen was trying to explain to me about
the war and the spirit and what her
family had meant and you know i thought
i understood what she was saying i
thought i got that
until that night in
2020 when she spoke to us at the darkest
moment
of the pandemic
and she gave us hope
she told us we would meet again
and it wasn't just that she empathized
with her situation that was that she
shared it
and i realized now that perhaps the
reason she held such a special place in
her heart
was because she shared our memories she
shared her thoughts she shared her pain
and she was also a link back to those
loved ones that we had lost who had been
through difficult times before
that she had also shared
and today the speeches the
reminiscencies the memories that we have
heard in this place have all been very
moving
but they've all had a touch
of gratitude
of thankfulness for having been part of
those 70 years of her reign
and a heartbreaking recognition
that that era has come to an end
but
there was also a moment i think when her
late majesty would have been extremely
proud to see our new king
devote himself to the service of this
country in the way that she had done
before
and so while we might find this parting
very sorrowful
and indeed heartbreaking
we now know that there is a future
when although our country will change we
will not have the constant figure we
have had for 70 years the transition
will be smooth
and there will be a future and it will
be good
so while we thank her majesty and wish
that she rests in peace
we know
that our future is secure
god save the king
thank you madam
speaker i rise on behalf of myself
and my constituents in northwest
cambridgeshire
to pay tribute to
the late her majesty the queen i think
it's fair to say that
all of us
in this chamber
have had her majesty as part of our
lives
and i mean that quite literally a part
of our lives
demonstrated an extraordinary sense of
duty and commitment to public service
her majesty has left an imprint
not only on our country
and the commonwealth
but also across the world
she holds the world record of being
featured on the most global currencies
and her passing
is being marked across the world for
example in india they are having a
national day of mourning this coming
sunday
as well as being our queen
she was of course a global figure with a
global understanding
and this was summed up when she spoke at
the commonwealth heads of government
meeting in kampala uganda in november
2007
when she said
recognizing that each one of us is made
up of layer upon layer of identity and
that each of our unique personalities
has ties to culture
religion
community
country and beyond
is the essence of open and tolerant
communities
like many others
i was very fortunate
to meet a majesty on a number of
occasions
the last time
was on 8th july of this year at windsor
castle
when i was sworn into the privy council
before receiving the seals of office for
northern ireland
i will treasure
her wonderful smile to me as i shook her
hand
and as i took the oath of allegiance
holding the bhagavad-gita
the hindu book used on such occasions
and after the ceremony i was allowed to
keep the copy on which i'd taken the
earth
madame deputy speaker
the occasion is all the more special for
me
because whilst there has subsequently
been a swearing whilst there was
subsequently a swearing into the privy
council done virtually
i was the last person to be sworn
personally by her majesty into the privy
council
it is extraordinary that so many global
leaders
confess in their auto in their
biographies
that on meeting her majesty they were so
so nervous
and then they add
that very quickly she put them at their
ease often with a joke
we will miss her madame deputy speaker
may i conclude by saying that my prayers
and thoughts are very much with the
royal family at this difficult time
and they are particularly with king
charles
as he takes on his enormous
responsibilities
god save the king yeah
thank you
thank you modern deputy speaker and on
behalf of my constituents of weavervale
i pay tribute in this period of mourning
to her late majesty queen elizabeth ii
a tribute for a remarkable and constant
presence that's the signature a
signature of duty
public service
and
selflessness a lesson to each and every
one of us in this chamber and beyond
those 70 years of public service
commemorated
by the platinum jubilee has touched
every part of our communities
nation commonwealth and globe
a sense
of permanence
stability
and constitutional leadership
neutrality from this political sphere
that reassuring constant
the honourable members have referred to
and right honourable members referred to
this evening provided by the late queen
elizabeth ii has been an enduring
feature in times of transition and of
war
and a figurehead
of celebration well that's been the
opening of the shopping city center
in runcorn in my constituency in 1972
or the commemorative
mug and the 50 pence coin that i
received as well as a fund street
parties in 1977
at the silverall jubilee as an 11 year
old boy now i really appreciate you
darren still do to this day
madame deputy speaker more recently that
reassuring compassion was evident in the
dark times of the covid pandemic
we now
enter another historical
transition while we mourn the loss
of the late queen elizabeth ii
i and my constituents
send our deepest sympathies to king
charles iii and the royal family
god
bless them
all may
may she
may um
the late queen
elizabeth ii
rest
in peace
peter alders
deputy speaker i rise on behalf of the
people of waveney to pay tribute to
her majesty the queen
with the nation's guiding light taken
from us there was last night for a
moment
from my perspective a sense of
helplessness
what do we do how are we going to get
home without her
the answer madam deputy speaker is that
we learn from the high standards of
dignity duty and humility
to which she had adhered both throughout
her life and her 70-year reign
we shall always fall short of the summit
that she reached but if we get to her
foothills we will have succeeded
great britain and the commonwealth have
faced numerous challenges over the past
70 years
and the world has changed a great deal
she was our shield to any arrows of
adversity
and despite the enormous
responsibilities that she bore on our
behalves
she never never put a foot wrong
her majesty was a family person and in
some respects we were all part of her
wider family
she enjoyed those things those aspects
of life that we all enjoy
animals and pets
whether corgis
ponies and horses or racing pigeons
family meals whether that be barbecues
picnics or christmas dinners
as we have heard her majesty had a
lifelong passion for horse racing
back in coronation week in 1953 her
horse oriole ran second in the derby the
nearest she ever got to securing that
cherished prize
one might have expected a hint of
disappointment
but there was none she joined the rest
of the nation
in celebrating the victory of national
icon sir gordon richards in his 28th and
final attempt to win the race for the
race for the first time an auriel madame
deputy speaker is a radiant light around
her head or body
our wheel has been extinguished but her
legacy will endure forever
speaker the queen ascended the throne as
we emerged from the ravages of the
second world war
as she departs
we face more adversity
and uncertain and worrying immediate
future
if we strive to conduct ourselves as she
did
if we apply a mere modicum of her wisdom
and sound judgment
then we will get through it
your majesty on behalf of the people of
waveney
thank you for all that you have done for
us
our deepest condolences to all of your
family
and god save the king
kirsty blackman
thank you very much for affording me the
opportunity to pay tribute on behalf of
my constituents on this sad day
aberdeen's had a long association and
with and fondness for the royal family
beautiful granite statues of former
monarchs can be found watching over many
parts of our city
people across aberdeen are feeling a
profound sense of loss today
in 1964 aberdeen suffered one of our
darkest hours
a typhoid outbreak in the city
hospitalized 500 people and led to three
fatalities dr ian mcqueen our chief
medical officer described aberdeen as a
sort of beleaguered city our reputation
as a centre for tourism was badly
damaged
hearing of our local issues and a very
short notice queen elizabeth diverted a
planned journey to glasgow in order to
visit aberdeen this thoughtful gesture
which expressed the queen's confidence
in the safety of visiting aberdeen has
been long remembered by our citizens
throughout the years her majesty's
retained a relationship with our city in
1970 she visited the vsa children's
centre in aberdeen's hardgate the
association of social service vsa has
been honoured to secure the patronage of
every monarch during their 150 year
history from their founding patronage of
queen victoria in 1870.
in 1990 queen elizabeth ii opened the
bona chord center in aberdeen the people
of aberdeen love to turn out for a
public event and this one was no
different with crowds throwing to try
and catch a glimpse of her even
aberdonians who were not present on that
day will almost certainly have walked
past the plaque that she unveiled to
commemorate that
in 2017 the queen again visited aberdeen
to open the robertson family roof garden
at aberdeen royal infirmary like so many
of my constituents i've had occasion to
seek solace in the roof garden while a
loved one was in hospital and we very
much appreciate that she came along to
open that i want also madame because
speaker to mention her majesty the
queen's long involvement with the girl
guiding movement in 1953 she became girl
guides patron and has remained a
stalwart supporter for all of her years
she first joined the guides age 11
taking part in campion trips and earning
badges for swimming
over the years thousands of girls and
young women across the uk and overseas
have worked hard to achieve the highest
award in guiding the queen's guides
badge
i want also to send my personal
condolences to the queen's family in
2011 my great-granny passed away
also well into her 90s i well remember
the devastation
and sense of shock that we all felt
somebody who had been there for so long
we had begun to think that she would be
a constant presence in our lives and
there would never be a day that we would
be without her presence i can feel
therefore an echo of what the royal
family of what the generations that
followed her must be feeling today and i
send out my heartfelt best wishes to
them at this time for getting through
this
difficult moment
from the people of aberdeen north
myanmar speaker i want to thank queen
elizabeth for her lifetime of service
felicity
thank you madam deputy speaker
on behalf of the residents of the royal
borough of kensington i want to pay the
deepest tribute to her late majesty the
queen
who served our country and the
commonwealth with the most remarkable
and selfless
devotion the queen's life was
intertwined
with the royal borough of kensington
and indeed her coronation robes were
actually woven in kensington at the
royal school of needlework which was
then in south kensington
many of the late queen's family live in
kensington at kensington palace
including her late sister princess
margaret
and of course currently it is the
official residence of the new prince and
princess of wales
the queen also sent her son
his majesty the king to his first school
in kensington which is hill house on
ponch street
we are delighted to have those
associations
with her late majesty and his majesty
the king
there are so many things i could talk
about the exceptional reign of her late
majesty
but i am going to focus on two things
the length of that reign
and her incredible empathy with her
people
her first official visit to the science
museum
was in 1930
at the age of 11 when she visited with
her sister and her grandmother
her last visit to the science museum was
in
2019 that is a relationship with one
institution spanning a remarkable 81
years
and she had those relationships in my
constituency whether it was with the v a
the natural history museum the
commonwealth institute which she was so
passionate about when it was in high
street kensington
remarkably someone said to me yesterday
that the queen's reign of 70 years
is actually
30
of the existence of the united states of
america that is remarkable
and secondly i want to talk about her
empathy with her people
during the course of the last 25 years
sadly my constituency has had two
tragedies
the grenfell tower far
and the ladbroke grove rail crash
in both instances the queen visited very
very quickly
and she gave the most remarkable
comfort and sucker
to the bereaved to the survivors and the
residents
she was so humble and she only thought
of those who were suffering rather than
of her own emotions
so
i want to thank you your majesty
i want to send all of the condolences
from the royal borough of kensington
to his majesty the king and his family
and i want to wish his majesty the king
a long and healthy reign
god save the king
muhammad
thank you very much mr deputy speaker
watching our family rushing to the
bedside of
the gravely ill queen yesterday will
have brought back traumatic
memories for many of us who have
received the heart stopping cool
with the news of the imminent death of a
loved one
for as
we remember
the 70 years of dedicated and loyal
service
from the queen
we first pay our respects to a grieving
family
we have lost a mother
a grandmother
a great grandmother
and a friend
who was very special
and so has our country
this is a profoundly
and moment sad moment for the uk
the commonwealth and the world
our queens
elizabeth ii
is an icon
throughout the world who makes our
nation proud
he earned our respect
and embodied all that is good
about public service
duty
fortitude and diligence
her reassurance her insurance presence
her dignity and constancy especially in
terms of discord bound us
in a way we may only be about to
understand
he has been a role model throughout
the ages i pay attribute to our
remarkable lives work
the legacy he leaves
the lives he has touched
will echo
through
the ages
it was a delight to see our community
come together
to celebrate the jubilee celebrations
the outpouring of love was heartfelt and
enduring
the days and months ahead will be very
difficult
may we come together in peace
kindness
this and respect as you remember
our queen and prepare for the next
chapter in our nation's history
on the behalf of the people of bethlehem
thank you ma'am and long long live the
king thank you andy percy thank you you
speak mr deputy speaker i rise to
associate my constituents with the
tributes that have been uh made today to
her late majesty and to on behalf of the
people of bringing ghoul and the isle of
axiom to swear our loyalty and commit
ourselves to our new king
we've had some fine tributes uh in this
chamber today and from leaders around
the world and one which resonated the
most with me was that of her majesty's
12th canadian prime minister who
yesterday said of her late majesty that
she was one of his favorite people in
the world and that resonated uh with me
uh i had didn't know her majesty uh her
majesty as obviously
mr trudeau did but it resonated with me
because we all felt that she was
somebody we knew and somebody who was
for me um
one of my favorite people and when i
think of why yes of course it's due to
her constitutional role and her role in
this country and all of her dedicated
service to this country but i think for
my generation it is also because she
represents the our grandparents
generation i was born in the year of her
silver jubilee i look a lot younger and
but it's but my grandparents were the
generation who were coming of age in
world war ii as she was coming to age
and
actually yesterday was the
anniversary some years earlier of the
very day that we rushed to my
grandfather's bed
to say goodbye to him uh uh and he so
loved the queen uh did uh donald
thiexton and my grandma betty who
collected everything there was uh to do
with the queen and as i say to my
generation uh i think she links us to
our grandparents and i haven't as others
have in this place perhaps this speaks
to my failures as a politician or a lack
of achievement haven't kneeled before
her majesty or had a sword put on my
shoulders or been provided with a kbe uh
or or or enter to the privy council but
i did this year for work outside of this
place received the uh queen's platinum
jubilee medal and it was one of the
proudest thing i received i didn't get
it at a castle i had to well we had to
drive to rotherham and pick it up from a
nhs office and but i was so proud
um to receive that medal and i will
cherish it forever more with the image
of her majesty on it i did meet her just
once in 2012
here i have no great story to tell of
that because i'm afraid
i rather let myself down we met her
as new members when she came to address
both houses and i was so flustered as
this working-class lab from hull meeting
the queen
i didn't know what to do and we were
given some protocol information
beforehand and all i remember is her
majesty i like majesty came up to our
group and before i could say anything or
before she could say anything i just in
my humber turns shouted out brigham
ghoul and she just looked at me smiled
and went oh and moved on to the next
member um so i do not have a uh a a
great story of our interaction um
but it was a a privilege and an honour
of my life to have met uh her late
majesty and on behalf of my constituents
i just wanted to thank her for a service
and can i just say as we say in the
jewish faith may her memory be a
blessing god save the king
mcmorren thank you mr deputy speaker and
on behalf of the people of cardiff north
it's a an honor to rise to pay tribute
and
offer my deepest condolences to his
majesty the king to the whole royal
family as they mourn the loss of their
mother grandmother and great-grandmother
queen elizabeth our longest serving
greatest monarch who devoted so much to
our country throughout her long and
exceptional life
and communities across cardiff north
share in
their grief
and as we all share in their grief
the magnitude of this loss cannot be
understated
through our lifetimes through difficult
times and upheaval whether at home or
abroad the queen has been our constant
for 70 years
her life of service dedication and her
love for all of us
demonstrates her values and these we
must hold on to as we move into a new
era keeping her memory alive in our
hearts through this historic moment of
change
and as a loyal public servant
her bond with all four nations of the uk
was unmatched and of course she loved
scotland
but i know she had a special place in
her heart for wales
she was gifted a playhouse
a boy within bach from the people of
wales when she was six
years old and which still is apparently
in the grounds of windsor
and when the senate was established she
insisted on being there in person for
every single royal opening which is
where i met her
and she surprised us all
with her absolute encyclopedic knowledge
of welsh politics
of devolution taking pride in the fact
that she knew every single detail
and she understood that role
and it what it had and what it has
with our constitution
and her connection to cardiff was strong
visiting many times not just to cheer
on in rugby and enjoy our music
footage from 1971 shows her opening
wales largest hospital
at university hospital wales spending
time
chatting with patients never holding
back always taking as much time as
possible with people her compassion
shining through
and we've seen that passion
her speech in cop 26 last year was one
of the most powerful speeches
calling on world leaders to act with
urgency on climate change
and her determination is only surpassed
by our now king a passionate
environmentalist and conservationist i'm
confident that his passion for combating
climate change
will shine through his reign
queen elizabeth was our symbol our
leader for so long but more than that
she was an incredible woman
unassuming principled kind and loving
she was able to leave when times were
difficult but she showed a constant love
for all of us something we all felt
we will miss that and as we mourn we
think of the loved ones we've lost
of loved ones we may not see and today
is a reminder to hold them close to
reach out to men scars and wounds and
move forward with love
life is short and if nothing else we
must remember what's most important
so to end i want to remember someone
close to me
and one of my late father's favorite
quotes from dylan thomas
do not go gentle into that good night
rage rage against the dying of the light
caroline ansel
thank you mr deputy speaker
i rise to extend the love and heartfelt
condolences being expressed in
eastbourne and willingdon today to his
majesty the king the royal family and
the royal household
how mightily our sovereign lady will be
missed
her legacy of course will be global in
its reach
but will find form in very local ways
too in my constituency
one such way will be in the shape of the
queen's green canopy
this 10-year community jubilee project
has a goal to plant 5 000 trees
from the foot of the south downs at
beads all the way to the highest point
in eastbourne at butts brow the project
will regenerate
and re-imagine this beautiful inspiring
landscape for generations yet to come
it's very special too that it was her
late majesty's father king george vi who
formally opened the town's downland in
1929
and perhaps rather poignant that it was
her late majesty
who planted the first jubilee tree
at balmoral
the project is a fitting tribute
as her late majesty's love of the great
outdoors is very well known
so too is her deep christian
faith one of the very first messages
of love and appreciation in eastbourne's
book of condolence today reads
in her wisdom charm devotion to duty and
warmth
she was a guiding light for our country
and so she was
in her humble and gracious way
the late queen would have testified to
the guiding light of christ in her life
in the very last devotion she used to
prepare for her coronation
she prayed
god be in my head
and in my
understanding
god be in mine eyes and in my looking
god be in my mouth and in my speaking
god be in my heart and in my thinking
god be at my end
and my departing
elizabeth windsor has run her race quite
majestically
may she now rest in peace and rise in
glory and god save the king
wilson
thank you mr deputy speaker
as we mourn the loss of her late majesty
and celebrate her extraordinary legacy i
wish to convey
condolences on behalf of my constituents
to the king and the entire royal family
we feel her loss deeply
twickenham is home to a royal palace a
royal park
more platinum jubilee street parties
than any other english borough
and a rugby stadium whose rousing
renditions of god save the queen
have now been heard for the final time
i wanted to share three very quick
stories of how the queen's kindness and
humility touched the lives of my
constituents
last year park lane stables a riding
center for disabled people in teddington
was facing eviction campaigners were
desperate to keep it open so as the
queen's love of horses is well known
they went straight to the top
natalie o'rourke describes the letter
they received back from the palace as
like a modern day fairy tale
it was an invitation to the royal muse
to visit her majesty's horses
one campaigner caitlyn said of the visit
we were drawn into their community
we mattered we were cared for
the queen could make everyone feel at
home
her late majesty visited twickenham many
times during her reign most often of
course it was for the rugby as she was
patron of the rfu for 64 years
tom gamor remembers the queen opening
twickenham stadium's east stand in 1994.
whilst he was a 13 year old boy ball boy
waiting in the players tunnel the queen
stopped greeted them and asked questions
of them all
he told me her grace and genuine
interest in each and every one of us
said everything about her human side and
her love for her role
my constituent the lord lieutenant of
greater london sir kenneth alisa
accompanied the queen to grenfell tower
in the days following the fire
despite the unbelievable tragedy when
the queen arrived the crowd broke out
into spontaneous applause
he said she showed then as she has so
many times her ability to unite
console and bring hope to that to her
people
in their times of need
i want to finish
by sharing what i personally most
admired about her
her deep christian faith
it underpinned her commitment to devote
her whole life to public service to her
country and her commonwealth
during the platinum jubilee the vicar of
saint mary's written auburn and
teddington reminded us of the words of
the queen's 2016 christmas message
christ's example she said
helps me to see the value of doing small
things
with great love
whoever does them
and whatever they themselves believe
queen elizabeth ii
did many things with great love
few of them were small
may she rest in peace god save the king
thank you mr deputy speaker and this is
the greatest of honor to be here today
to rise and pay my tribute on behalf of
my constituents in derby north and of
course of myself
since the heartbreaking news of
yesterday that simply took my breath
away i have been reflecting on the
influence you've had on myself and so
many across the world
all of my life i have known of the
legacy that she has given us all of my
life i have mirrored this amazing woman
and today my heart is so sad to say
goodbye to her
she was universally our queen and she
cared so passionately for us all and
truly embodied what it means to serve
she promised to devote her whole life to
serving her people and her generous
heart never missed a beat
it was a heart of compassion
love and kindness through joyous times
and turbulent times
so difficult that i can hardly imagine
yet she carried herself with grace and
dignity a dignity
a role model for future generations just
like my wonderful granddaughter
she was the very best of all of us the
very best of humanity
strong yet compassionate
loving and steadfast
she laughed with us as a country her
fantastic smile lighting up our lives
she mourned with us and led us through
the darkest of times
a great diplomat
leader mother
wife grandmother and great grandmother
and like me an animal lover
she carried us through the very worst of
times and has held our hand through the
very best
i know that my constituents of derby
north thanked the queen from the bottom
of their hearts for a lifetime of
service for her guidance and for a never
faltering service
to quote king charles iii
a life well lived
thank you your majesty
rest in peace
thank you uh mr deputy speaker i rise to
pay a tribute on behalf of my
constituents of lewisham east and myself
our late queen elizabeth ii is the
nation's longest-serving monarch who
reigned for over for reigns for seven
decades she was for so many of us a
constant enduring and a reliable figure
for our great nation i was deeply
saddened by the news that our beloved
queen had passed away
she served her country with dignity and
grace and one of the finest quotes i've
heard recently about her is neither did
she explain herself and neither did she
complain
she rose to each challenge with grace
and she dedicated her life to her nation
she was a queen who loved and in return
was loved one of my earliest memories of
meeting the queen was when i was seven
years old i met her during a visit to
southeast london
strangely enough my mother's earliest
memory of seeing the cream was around
the same age many years earlier in the
caribbean
my mother said in jamaica children used
to run to her and nothing really changed
there
she is adored by so many across the
commonwealth and indeed our globe
and of course as a child my greatest
street party was in 1977
the silver jubilee and i fear that many
people are giving away their age because
we all seem to remember the silver
jubilee
she gave us all so much cause for joy
and celebration and i'm grateful that
she was able to mark her platinum
jubilee earlier this year
this brought together thousands of
people from across lewisham where there
were over a hundred street parties that
were held to celebrate her many
achievements
her departure reminds me that there is a
time to live and indeed a time to die
but let's all do our very best to do
what we can while we live to make a
difference in the lives of others in
this place
but in the meantime my thoughts are with
her family with our nation and for all
who mourn
our beloved queen elizabeth ii of the
united kingdom of great britain and
northern ireland but also across the
commonwealth and across the globe may
she rest in peace and long live the king
john howell
thank you mr deputy speaker
i recall my first encounter with the
queen's visit to a foreign country
this was in 1994
and this was the visit that she she did
to russia
she went to moscow and saint petersburg
at the request of boris yeltsin
i'd been invited along
as part of this trip to conduct economic
negotiations with russia
it was based in saint petersburg
on board britannia
a ship which thoroughly impressed all
the russian visitors
the press made much of the difficulty
for the queen of the trip
the press were
obsessed with the details of which
jewels she had brought and whether any
of them had once belonged to rush
russian duchesses she wasn't in the
slightest interested in this
and i must admit that she took boris
yeltsin fully in her stride which is
something that that is quite remarkable
to see
if you can remember what what he was
like
it was a great success for uk plc
and the queen took a great interest in
what we were doing and the results of of
of that visit
as his majesty said earlier we remember
a life well lived
we celebrate that life
for all the human qualities as well as
the duty and service which so many
members have spoken about
god save the king
ian paisley thank you very much mr
deputy speaker
forgetting the things which are behind
us
and reaching
for the things which are before us
pressing on to the mark to the high
calling of god
through jesus christ the words of the
apostle i think not only are the
religious philosophy
of our former monarch but also indicate
her style of leadership
she didn't allow the past to be a burden
she didn't allow the past to hold her
back
she stretched forward constantly to the
mark shooing this country forward
to a better place
to an ideal
to getting over a line
and indeed her christmas speeches each
year summed that up
as she witnessed for her lord and savior
and for her god i must say i was deeply
impressed and struck by the speech this
evening by the king
where he dedicated himself
to his mother's god
in a powerful way and in a singular way
and i think that that should be an
encouragement to us all that have he
learns from that example of
urging this kingdom forward in all its
strands and it's all its steps my my
constituents are broken-hearted i'm sure
like yours mr deputy speaker with what
has happened over the last few years to
our kingdom
but they will be emboldened by the
memories of her majesty's visits
certainly her last visit to northampton
where she visited the bush mills
bushmills looked like the box of quality
street a contingent of the irish guards
decked out in red tunics sheamus the dog
walking through the village
whenever the queen arrived to unveil the
statue of
the war hero quake
she said to me as i welcomed her is this
all yours
i hesitated i said no mom this is yours
and she twinkle in her eyes she said
quite
i'll never forget it i'll never forget
it it was it was a lovely moment
king charles when he was prince charles
was in the constituency also he was way
down in grace hill in balamina but for
some reason he too made it to bushmills
i don't know what it is but there's
something about
a liquid which sits in a barrel for 12
years that he seems to like
and i know that my constituents are
delighted by his patronage of uh
bushmills you know but our kingdom is a
lesser place
we have lost a wonderful sovereign lay
but i
do want to
repeat what the king said this evening
let's draw strength
from the light
of her example
let's draw strength from the light of
her example
god save the king
james wilde
thank you very much mr deputy speaker
it's only three months ago that i stood
here to join in the wonderful tributes
to her majesty the queen to mark her
platinum jubilee and today the house and
the country feels immense sadness at her
passing but that is tempered by the
opportunity to recognize her
extraordinary life of service and by
knowing that she witnessed the heartfelt
displays of affection towards her in the
70th year of her reign
and that unprecedented occasion was
celebrated passionately in my north west
norfolk constituency which is
unsurprising as it's home to sandringham
the much-loved private retreat of the
late queen and her family for
generations
and the continuity that that estate has
provided to her family means her norfolk
home occupied a unique place in the
queen's affections she loved the time
that she spent there
harry ascended to the throne at success
from the public eye
a place where she could relax with
family
was often spotted behind the wheel of
the land rover and she enjoyed walking
her dogs and of course the country
pursuits and her prized horse stud
the people living in the villages around
the sandringham state have great
affection for the queen and she was a
very special part of those close-knit
communities they have happy memories of
encounters with the queen because as
well as the private time she spent there
she chose to undertake many visits over
the years and whether as a member of the
sandringham wi since 1943
and then as its president taking tea and
cake with ladies
or presenting local
children with awards or visiting
charities and businesses she was a
constant and cherished part of life in
west norfolk
and perhaps surprisingly she was even
able to go about her life there without
fuss
indeed famously went out shopping one
day a woman remarked to her you look
just like the queen
to which the queen is said to have
replied how reassuring
presumably with a twinkle in her eye and
her affection with sandra was matched
only by that of the duke of edinburgh
who gave such love support and service
to her majesty
it was from the long library at
sandringham that the queen delivered the
first televised christmas message in
1957
but perhaps one of the most profound
comments in recent times with their
broadcasts during the pandemic that
others have referred to that we all meet
again a simple phrase expressing hope
that we all needed
and it was the immediate response to her
passing yesterday was people coming
together at windsor at buckingham palace
at sandringham of balmoral and elsewhere
to share their grief and give thanks for
an amazing life
and on behalf of my north west norfolk
constituents i offer the deepest
condolences to the entire royal family
god save the
and
king
kaiser
thank you mr deputy speaker and i rise
to pay my respects today on behalf of my
constituents and airdrie and shots it is
of course with great sadness that we are
here today to pay tribute to her majesty
the queen
over her 70-year reign she's been a
figurehead across four nations and
worldwide and she has worked tirelessly
demonstrating an unwavering commitment
to herville as head of state
her majesty of course took the throne in
her twenties
and in the years that followed she
guided the four nations through
monumental changes she served as a
pillar of hope and stability during
times of uncertainty and she was a
constant in the lives of many people
indeed the only monarch many of us have
ever known mr deputy speaker i was born
in scotland but i'm also the grandchild
of the commonwealth and i know that many
species especially of the older
generations like my grandfather salam te
begum and my grandfather hajj abdullah
held the queen in high esteem
and they often when i was growing up
would tell us stories about when they
moved from a small village called sarabi
in pakistan to
watchdale then settling in scotland
they'll tell us about how they found the
queen as an inspiration to them and
simply her majesty meant so much to so
many people
she was of course a mother a grandmother
and a
and i along with the people of air drain
shots send our condolences to our family
they are in our thoughts and prayers may
she rest in peace
flick drummond
thank you very much um mr deputy speaker
for giving me this opportunity to pay
tribute on behalf of myself and my
constituents in me and bali to her
majesty queen elizabeth and to pass on
our condolences to the um to the uh
so to the king the queen consult and all
the royal family
this is one of the saddest times this
this country has faced
we have lost our guide and we feel the
strange sensation of being adrift that
something's not quite right in the world
that our anchor has been swept away
it is an unease i know that will fade as
life goes on and i know her majesty
would want it that way
she was a woman without retention solely
dedicated to her country in the
commonwealth through her unstinted
service up to her final days as we saw
how we will miss her smile and her
continuity
we knew this time would come but it was
a shock nonetheless
i want to thank her majesty for those 70
years of service she will remain an
example for everyone in particular those
in public service about how we should
serve it has been a leadership which so
many of us would like to emulate
the tributes from across the world show
what an inspiration she has been and
they must be a comfort to her family and
to the country as we come to terms with
our collective loss
i was born 10 years after the queen came
to the throne and like many are here i
have only known one monarch
the monarchy has been part of our
islands fabric for more than a thousand
years
it has been left in good shape and with
an able successor at its home
i will be proud to serve his majesty
king charles iii as member of parliament
in this british subject
god save the king
ruth cadbury
thank you mr deputy speaker
i want to add my thoughts and
condolences and that of my family and my
constituents to the royal family today a
time of immense grief and pain for them
as they've not only lost their sovereign
but also the beloved head of their
family
few remember a time without queen
elizabeth ii
her christmas messages her visits and
her presence at state occasions for 70
years she was a beacon and guiding light
for us all and as a woman in the public
eye she was a perfect example of grace
and dignity often in the face of
adversity
for many of my constituents in brentford
and isworth and hounslow australian
chiswick
the queen was known
through her tireless work to promote and
celebrate dialogue and tolerance between
all faiths and cultures
that's why i particularly remember her
2004 christmas message
where she described her visit both to a
mosque in east london and to the guara
in my constituency
in that message she then relayed the
story of a visitor to britain who had
described travelling from heathrow into
london on the piccadilly line at the end
of the school day
and of being delighted that children
from different cultures and faiths
getting on and off the tube train could
be at such ease with each other
something not possible in his own
country
many of those young people would have
been my constituents and attending our
local schools
in times of crisis the nation turned to
her for her compassion and her wisdom
from her speech to children being
evacuated during world war ii to her
national message at the height of the
coronavirus
the people of the uk turned to her
majesty at the most testing times
she always upheld her promise to serve
that she made when she was 21.
she devoted herself to service to our
country to the commonwealth and to us
all
today
marks the end of the
elizabethan age
but her majesty's memory and her legacy
shall live on
may she rest in peace
long live king charles iii
thank you very much mr deputy speaker i
rise to speak on behalf of the
constituents of loughborough
barrow salby hathan mount sorrell and
the world's villages to express their
deep sorrow at the loss of our sovereign
her majesty the queen
loughborough had the privilege of
hosting her majesty on a number of
occasions during her reign including in
1996
when she opened the new english and
drama building at loughborough grammar
school which was named the queen's
building in her honor
her majesty also visited in 1966
when she signed and sealed the royal
charter of incorporation that granted
university status to loughborough
college of technology becoming
loughborough university
we were also very proud to be involved
in the queen's baton relay in the lead
up to the commonwealth games in
birmingham this summer
i spoke on behalf of loughborough
constituency in the humble address
speech for her plattingham jubilee
earlier this year saying that the
commonwealth is of course the jewel in
the crown
and throughout her reign her majesty has
overseen its modernization to ensure
that it represents everyone that brings
together communities from across the
world and that is undoubtedly true
loughborough will again be on the world
stage this weekend when bells will ring
across the country and across the world
many of those bells will have been made
in loughborough at taylor's bell foundry
the world's largest working bell foundry
including the casting of the great pool
bell at some pools cathedral
we will be filled with both sadness and
great pride that our bells say goodbye
to our sovereign queen
and also welcome our new monarch king
charles iii
loughborough is honored to play its part
in marking this solemn and moving
occasion in british history
in closing i quote her late majesty when
she said grief is the price we pay for
love
there will be a great deal of grief felt
over these next few weeks and that is
because there was a great deal of love
for her throughout the 96 years of her
life
truly elizabeth the great
may she rest in peace and god save the
king
sam terry
thank you mr deputy speaker i'd like to
place on record my tribute today
alongside so many that have spoken today
already and of my personal condolences
to his majesty king charles iii on
behalf of all of our communities in
ilford south
mr deputy speaker like many
parliamentarians across the house i have
always had a profound respect for the
queen and for the role she has performed
within our nation i've admired the sage
advice and wise counsel she gave to so
many leaders over the course of the past
seven decades
and as a son of an anglican rectum
cannon of uh chelmsford cathedral
someone has grown up in the church
someone who has grown up in the churches
of ilford i've understood so much as
part of my life the role that the queen
has performed as head of the church of
england and in a constituency like
ilford where people really do do god
alongside their politics with so many
people of so many faiths attending
religious institutions on a daily basis
she has been held so fondly in the
hearts of so many for her religious
beliefs and her faith
but also of course because of her public
service
the queen's longevity is perhaps
encapsulated best in the fact that the
first prime minister she saw in winston
churchill was born in 1874 while the
current income of number 10 that she
created just days ago was born in 1975 a
span of more than 100 years an entire
century which is truly astounding
but she was also an inspiration to our
nation a steadying influence for
millions to look up to him with the
turbulence and flux so often in british
politics
she was the anchor that so many needed
during times of crisis
i remember very clearly witnessing the
strength she had in the wake of the
seven seven bombings that hit london and
the streets of our capital
she was able to show her tenderness in
meeting the victims
of the terrorist atrocities while at the
same time stating defiantly and i quote
that those who perpetrate these brutal
acts against innocent people should know
they would not change our way of life
and they did not
she was also an inspiration for our war
generation
my great-grandparents and grandparents
who served fighting the nazis
a shining light on the role that a woman
performed tirelessly in those war years
reading the story about haley aged just
18 in 1944 she begged her father king
george to let her join the war effort
perhaps unsurprisingly the king recently
refused to let her do so
however undeterred she continued to
plead with her father until he finally
relented and led her to join the
auxiliary territorial service she was
soon donning a pair of coveralls driving
a military truck and working as a
mechanic in doing so queen elizabeth
became the first woman in the royal
family to join the armed forces and the
first serving monarch to do so in over a
thousand years
and in the immediate aftermath of the
second world war in fact day after ve
day in 9th may 1945 elizabeth took part
in a tour of some of the bombed areas of
ilford in recognition of the terrible
conditions that east london and that
part of essex had endured under the
relentless bombing raids of the
luftwaffe
on her walkabout where she joined by
king george the queen other than
princess margaret she was on lay street
not far from my constituency office in
ilford next to that time the bombed out
local cinema
throughout her time as the monarch
elizabeth was always supportive of the
people of wilford i recall one of her
last trips silford when she visited
valentine's mansion in valentine's park
to mark her diamond jubilee in 2012.
crowds thronged to that park and is
abundantly clear the love and respect
that people from every generation and
across every community had for the queen
and as head of the commonwealth the
queen was held in particularly high
regard by my constituents in ilford many
of which were represented by her with
their origins and heritage in the 54
countries that our commonwealth now
extends to
and deputy speaker i'll quickly relay
one very quick uh memento of my meeting
with the queen there was a young scout
in the second seven kings troop from
milford where i saw first-hand the work
that elizabeth did as the patron of the
scout movement and i recall very fondly
actually climbing to the top of a tree
in gilworld park so i could actually
walk her see her walk past my scout
master asked me to come down and to
speak to her directly because even at
such a young age the work she did with
the movement of scouts was its patron
was an inspiration so in closing i would
like to send my heartfelt condolences
her death caused a long shadow over our
nation and all within the commonwealth
but the lessons that she taught us will
live on for many years to come god rest
the queen god blessed all her mourner
and long lived the king
simon banks
thank you mr deputy speaker across the
length and breadth of my constituency of
kluid south people have paid heartfelt
tribute to her late majesty the queen
part of what made the queen so special
was her combination of majesty and
modesty which made her both a remarkable
head of state and an approachable person
who millions have enjoyed meeting or
seeing at close quarters at home and
abroad
include south people have been recalling
her many visits over the years including
to corwin in 1949 when she was still
princess elizabeth and then
tatlangothlin in 1953 in her
post-coronation tour when she attended
the klangothelin international
musicalized steadford and took a trip on
the langothelin steam railway these
visits continued over the years to over
to nandi wrexham and elsewhere and in
all cases people felt a special
connection with this smiling friendly
and unassuming monarch supported so
magnificently by prince philip
unlike many other speakers here today
i've never had the honor of meeting the
queen in person but i am proud to say
that both my mother and i
shared the same birthday as her majesty
the queen namely the 21st of april
also as a small boy in 1964 i remember
the excitement in my own family when my
father
who commanded the queen's guard at
balmoral and we all spent the summer
staying in ballota while he carried out
his official duties supported by my
mother like everyone else that i have
met who served the queen in an official
capacity my father thought the world of
her
as has been mentioned many times
yesterday there were rainbows over both
buckingham palace and windsor castle
and i like to think of her reign as a
rainbow of dedicated service overarching
my life and that of the nation
and i felt this most strongly in the
wonderful address she gave the nation
april two years ago which again many
members have referred to at the start of
the covet crisis in which she said
the moments when the united kingdom has
come together to applaud its care and
essential workers will be remembered as
an expression of our national spirit
and its symbol will be the rainbows
drawn by children
the queen embodied our national spirit
with her great sense of community
kindness and dedicated service for which
we are eternally grateful
my thoughts and prayers and those of my
constituents include south are with her
beloved family god rest her soul god
save the king
and bless the prince and princess of
wales
dear hob house
thank you mr deputy speaker on this sad
day i rise to pay tribute
to her late majesty queen elizabeth ii
we are a nation in mourning
and i know i speak on behalf of my bath
constituents when i say
we will all sorely miss her
whether you had met her late majesty in
person or not
we feel we knew her
she had a personal relationship with all
her subjects
and she managed to combine her office as
monarch of an ancient and great kingdom
with the warmth and personal touch
of a wonderful human being
and her great personal qualities of
empathy
integrity
and humility
stood as an example to us all
she of all person who could have been
pompous was never pompous
she saw herself as a servant
all her life
that's rare
and we all owe her a huge debt of
gratitude
for that unstinging service
she was not just a british monarch she
was a world leader renowned and
respected throughout the world i grew up
in hanover in germany and there were no
more monarchs actually everybody was
rather squeamish about tradition but
with a royal connection between britain
and hanover people were perfectly happy
to adopt queen elizabeth as our queen
and indeed when i was young
she was
perfectly useful and to correct our
manners
you better learn to behave in case you
meet the queen
apart from her undoubtedly impeccable
table manners
she represented to the core
the best of british
in time of great turbulence the late
queen stood as unifier and a peacemaker
she clearly
loved people and respected each and
every individual
for who they were
her legacy
must live on
as we enter a new chapter
may she rest in peace
and long live the king
jagram
some wonderful tributes mr deputy
speaker been given today from across the
house to a simply amazing woman
our nation's
unshakable rock in storms our favorite
granny and above all our queen
much loved and now deeply mourned in
gloucester
as across the united kingdom and abroad
for her late majesty touched lives not
just in the 14 countries for whom she
was head of state or even the 54
countries that make up the commonwealth
family but across the world
on july the first this year
i representing her majesty's government
at the inauguration of president marcos
of the philippines past congratulations
from the world's longest serving head of
state to its most recently elected
the president's face lit up
the queen is amazing he said
we all watched the platinum jubilee
celebrations and she has set the
platinum standard for heads of state
now whatever our individual memories
of
her late majesty
whether of individual meetings or seeing
her visits like those to gloucester in
2003 and nine or simply watching her
smash hits on tv with james bond and
paddington bear
the president was right
the queen is
was the platinum standard
the
extraordinary example of leadership
through service to which we all aspire
so in offering my and gloucester
residents sympathy to the royal family
we are all grateful for that
extraordinary legacy
none of us will ever forget our world's
queen
or her second great elizabethan age and
i believe king charles's own long record
of service and his moving speech this
evening should give us all great
confidence for the future
thank you mom god save the king
james murray
thank you mr deputy speaker
mr deputy speaker this morning i left my
constituency of healing north to come
into parliament by boarding an elizabeth
line train
as we know over time queen elizabeth the
second mark on our banknotes our coins
and our stamps and so on will gradually
give way to the mark of king charles iii
but in our part of the country those
stations and trains mean that my
constituents and i will always have a
physical tribute to our greatest monarch
running through our borough
mr deputy speaker to the great
disappointment of the countless primary
school children who have asked me since
i was elected i never had the chance of
meeting the queen as an mp
but i know that i was not alone in
feeling her presence across greenford
perivale north thought hanwell and
ealing during the platinum jubilee
celebrations in june
in our diverse part of london people of
all ages of all backgrounds of all
faiths and none came out to celebrate
the reign of our queen
and our love of our community and our
country
after the separation of a pandemic we
were celebrating the queen's jubilee
with our neighbors
and that celebration itself
helped the queen's assurance during
lockdown the better days would return
come true
and at those jubilee celebrations as in
the house of commons today
everyone had their personal reflection
on the queen and what it was about her
they most admired
for me
what stands out above all else was her
most incredible sense of duty and her
awesome devotion to service that quite
simply was her life
mr deputy speaker on behalf of the
people of eli north i offer our deepest
condolences to the king and the royal
family and our most heartfelt thanks for
the life of queen elizabeth ii whose
legacy will live on forever
paul bristow
yeah thank you mr deputy speaker it's my
solemn honor to pay tribute to her late
majesty queen elizabeth ii
on behalf
the people of my city peterborough
peterborough loved
and mourned her
her reign managed somehow
across its seven decades
to penetrate each of our lives and bring
us together
now we are brought together
in grief
my constituents come from across the
commonwealth and beyond it
she mattered to each of them
that was her magic
and i saw it at work myself throughout
the jubilee celebrations in my city just
a few months ago different cultures
religions creeds different nationalities
all coming together to celebrate a truly
remarkable woman
for our armed forces for our public
servants for organizations charities and
families and for me
there is one less certainty
in an all too turbulent world
she visited peterborough in 1952 while
still princess elizabeth attending the
agricultural show at the old showground
in eastfield and as our queen she
visited on four more occasions
in march 1975 the morny thursday service
was held at peterborough cathedral
mostly distributed the royal maundy
coins to 49 men
and 49 women in a ceremony attended by
more than 3 200 people
she later went for a walking bridge
street and dined with her husband the
late duke of edinburgh and with city
councillors at the town hall
the queen returned to peterborough for a
silver jubilee
again arriving to crowds of people at
peterborough station
she opened our magistrates court and the
crescent in britain
while not forgetting to make a detail to
the national shy horse society's
centenary show
another decade on when she returned for
the 750th
anniversary of our cathedral
she also opened the edith cavale
hospital now peterborough city hospital
a final visit was to the east of england
show where over three thousand visitors
made their way through the turnstiles an
extra three thousand to catch a glimpse
of her majesty
sadly she will never return
i find it difficult to put into words
it feels
like losing
a family member
even though
i never met her
the institution
is far more
than the individual
but the crown was greater for resting on
her head
no monarch brought selfless dedication
to the role
asked of them
few before held the strings to our
country's heart
with her majesty queen elizabeth ii
the most tangible connection
to our history is gone
but with his majesty the king charles
iii a legacy will continue long into our
future
peterborough proudly proclaims
through its tears
god save the king
alex davis jones
mr deputy speaker i am saddened but
truly grateful and humbled to have the
opportunity to add to my tributes here
today to commemorate the extraordinary
life of her royal highness queen
elizabeth ii on behalf of my
constituents and my community into
pontepre and tafili may i first echo the
sentiments of colleagues across the
benches in offering my sincere
condolences to the royal family and all
who knew and loved her
while we all know what it may feel like
to lose someone close it is difficult to
comprehend the loss of such a central
figure knowing fully well the whole
world outside is watching
mr deputy speaker i share the sentiments
of a huge number of local residents who
have been in touch to share their sorrow
at the news of her majesty's passing
mainly my mom but then she did name me
alexandra mary
many of my constituents also have great
pride in working at the royal mint
enclave scent and they have spent their
working lives ensuring her portrait is
nothing short of picture perfect on all
of the coins in our pockets
they have expressed their admiration for
her royal highness's lifetime of
dedicated public service and her
commitment and devotion to this great
nation
as history's longest serving monarch her
majesty played an incredibly important
role in uniting the nation through
turbulent times
her majesty loved this country she loved
wales and we all loved her in return
which is why we all grieve today and for
what i imagine will be some time to come
all of us here in the uk and across the
commonwealth are indebted to her majesty
we have so much to be grateful to her
for
and for that i say thank you joachim
vaudeman
her majesty was committed to the demands
of duty the sacrificed sources of
service and understood the
responsibility bestowed upon her
listening to colleagues across the house
today recant stories and tales of
meeting her majesty in person i too
would like to share with you all my most
cherished memory of my encounter with
the late queen
as a little girl who always dreamed like
so many of one day becoming a princess
having the privilege of singing for her
majesty as part of her globally of a
golden jubilee tour in triharvard is a
day i shall never forget
waving my paper flag a dry gokh
belting out calallen lawn with foil and
getting to see with my own eyes the
actual real-life queen was nothing short
of magical
she had a natural sparkle a wicked sense
of humor and the ability to make
everyone she spoke to
waved at or simply smiled at feel like
they had the most treasured interaction
we may never see another monarch like
her as a nation we will miss her majesty
enormously may she rest in peace and
rising glory god save the king and god
bless the new prince and princess of
wales
grief is the price we pay for love mr
deputy speaker as the queen herself so
memorably said
and as i laid flowers outside buckingham
palace this morning i was struck by the
scale of the grief
felt at her passing
for as my honorable friend the member
for loughborough said the greater the
love
the greater the grief
in some ways mr deputy speaker the queen
was an ordinary woman a person like us
she loved dogs marching about in wellies
horse racing ajin and duvonne a good
wind up
and sporting the ultimate rainbow hued
wardrobe
if i wore beige no one would knew who i
was she is reported to have said
like us she suffered grief loss and
family troubles
but had to endure them being played out
on the pages of the world's press
she did so with great dignity
we felt we could relate to her that we
knew her even though many of us may
never have met her she held a special
place in our hearts
and in many ways of course the queen was
also an extraordinary woman
there can't be many who can pull off
walking in a one kilogram crown
but also claim to know their way around
a car engine
or who have let brian may serenade them
from the roof of their house
few could have provided such stability
and reassurance
through seven decades of the greater
social economic and technological change
adapting to that change
without letting it change her
her reign saw the first man on the moon
the invention of the internet
when she ascended the throne great
britain had an empire when she passed
away she was the head of a family of
nations
and she was head of our national family
constituents in rushcliff have told me
her loss feels personally
more perhaps than they imagined
whatever our politics or creed from the
youngest to the oldest
from the most remote corners of our
islands to the bustle and clatter of our
biggest cities
the queen bound us together
the thread through our national story
in triumph she was our anthem through
trials our strength
her courage and steadfastness an example
to us all
who will ever forget her message to the
nation at the height of the coronavirus
pandemic
her reassurance that we would meet again
and we meet here today
to remember a woman who lit people's
faces with joy
to remember a sovereign whose reign is
one of the greatest in history
and to remember a public servant who
gave her whole life to us
her people her country and her
commonwealth right until the very end
thank you mr deputy speaker
throughout her extraordinary reign her
late majesty queen elizabeth ii was a
beacon of stability duty and
selflessness
and many of my constituents and albans
will find it impossible to imagine
britain's public life without her
on a personal level i met the queen a
number of times when i worked in
commonwealth affairs trying to advance
democracy and human rights
the queen wasn't just a constant but a
few times a year she was literally part
of the day job
commonwealth heads of government
meetings commonwealth youth meetings the
annual multi-faith interfaith
commonwealth day service and reception
the queen and commonwealth were
inseparable the only modern
intergovernmental organization like it
each year we commonwealth secretariat
staffers used to love celebrating the
diversity of the commonwealth on
commonwealth day
but sometimes it was slightly surreal
the annual commonwealth day reception at
the secretariat was rumored to be the
only event in the queen's diary
where she didn't know who she was going
to meet
there was no official lineup it was all
organic not organized and there was no
protocol on ordering people and guests
by rank or into different rooms
as a result it was not unusual to see
the queen greeting a disorganized throng
of diplomats high commissioners often
with their husbands and wives
jostling to a backdrop of fijian dancers
in coconut bras ghanaian acrobats and
british pop stars from the 1980s all
jockeying for position to get a glimpse
of the queen or to shake her hand
on another day i was tasked with taking
a group of dignitaries to buckingham
palace for an audience with her majesty
one such dignitary had just got a new
smartphone and he was particularly keen
on telling all the other group members
about the merits of this phone in
spectacular levels of detail
when we arrived at the palace we were
all told quite rightly to turn our
phones onto silent and to put them away
but during our polite conversation with
the queen this particular person tried
to persuade her majesty that she should
get a phone just like his so he
proceeded to take his phone out of his
pocket started pressing buttons and
thrust it under her nose and he plucked
up the courage to say your majesty i
think you get a phone like mine
we all stood there stunned in silence
and he just said
who do you expect me to text
it was fantastic
he blushed like a schoolboy
that one liner was wildly refreshing and
the rest of the group were incredibly
grateful
i know that so many people who have met
the queen have many memories and stories
to share including many of my own
constituents
and many of them will remember the three
occasions that the queen has visited
arson albans cathedral and abbey where a
book of condolence is now open
the queen's passing feels like an end of
an era but on behalf of myself and my
constituents in saint albans i would
like to extend my thoughts and prayers
to the royal family
rest in peace your majesty and thank you
thank you mr speaker i rise to speak on
behalf
of my constituents in west dorset
to pay tribute to our late queen whom we
have loved and admired for our entire
lives
to share in the deepest sorrow of the
nation and to send our deepest sympathy
to king charles and the royal family
queen elizabeth has been one of the few
constants
in our transitory life
the past 24 hours has truly brought home
to us
not only the life and service of our
queen but also our own service to our
community
and nation
queen elizabeth was a woman of great
kindness and faith
of incredible inspiration
of steadfast leadership
and was a family role model for all of
us
the queen was of my grandparents
generation
their sense of selfless service and duty
particularly during times of difficulty
has allowed us to lead the lives of
freedom and democracy that we enjoy
today
her late majesty's generation
is one of selflessness
not of entitlement
her generation is one of tenacity
of character
and of wisdom that we must look to
continue in our own lives
and since my own grandparents passed
away
i and so many have looked upon our queen
as the grandmother of the nation
and that is why the loss we feel is so
sad
and so difficult to describe
i am not able to put it better than
martin lee the rector of sherborne this
morning when he said
our country has been held in her hands
with gentleness and firmness she has
never let go
always putting the needs of the nation
before herself
in west dorset we have the fondest
memories of many occasions that the late
queen elizabeth visited us
first in 1952 in our county town of
dorchester
she visited my hometown of sherborne
twice once in 1998
when the queen unveiled the great west
window at sherbourne abbey and again as
part of the queen's diamond jubilee tour
in 2012 returning to dorchester in 2016
to open queen mother square in pinbury
those fond memories have endured with us
for many years and will continue to do
so
we
the people of west dorset
and the citizens of the united kingdom
mourn our queen
but our new king and his family are
mourning his mother
it is therefore with profound affection
and the greatest sympathy from west
dorset
that i wish his majesty the king to know
that he
the royal family
and the late queen elizabeth remain
steadfastly in our thoughts and prayers
at this very sad time god save the king
gerald jones
thank you very much mr speaker on behalf
of myself my family and my constituents
in the county borough of martha tibor on
the upper remnant valley i send my
sincere condolences to his majesty the
king and all members of the royal family
as we know and as we've heard most of
our fellow citizens have known no other
monarchy majesty queen elizabeth ii has
been an ever-present rock of stability
throughout our country the commonwealth
and around the world her presence has
indeed been the glue holding our country
together for so long and as we've heard
it's so difficult to think of our
country without her
i feel there is no greater example of
unstinting and exemplary public service
anywhere
we have been so lucky to have lived
during these times to have witnessed a
service for grace her dignity which was
an example to us all
we will undoubtedly never see her like
again
from an early age her majesty followed
her parents example of duty that was so
important in holding the country
together during world war ii
for over 70 years she has been a
constant she has demonstrated a lifelong
commitment to the service of the nation
and commonwealth she was the longest
reigning monarch in british history the
longest reigning female monarch and the
second longest serving monarch in world
history
she served right to the very end as she
declared that she would do on her 21st
birthday in 1947.
just a few short weeks ago communities
across all four nations of the united
kingdom and across the other realms the
commonwealth and the world were all
celebrated in the first ever platinum
jubilee
i hope that has she appeared on the
buckingham palace balcony for the last
time and witnessed the outpouring on the
mall that she was in no doubt just how
much she was loved
i know that we all have examples of
majesty's links to our communities and
in my constituency the most poignant is
the community of abervang a place where
her elite majesty visited following the
tragedy in 1966 and visited a number of
times during her reign something that
was a comfort to many in the village and
beyond her last visit to the community
was part of her diamond jubilee tour in
2012 when she opened the brand new annis
owen primary school
so mr speaker on behalf of the people
across my constituency i say thank you
for your life of service ma'am
may rest in eternal peace and rising
glory and god save the queen and god
bless the new prince and princess of
wales
thank you thank you mr speaker and that
was an excellent tribute like so many
tributes today as we and it just goes to
show how we're all united in our grief
the heartfelt speeches from across the
house have echoed the pain and sorrow
which has been felt across the country
and the commonwealth since that
devastating news yesterday on behalf of
my constituents in meridian i'd like to
express my heartfelt condolences to the
royal family as they mourn the loss of a
beloved mother grandmother and a great
grandmother our nation weeps with them
and for them
and her majesty does hold a special
place in the hearts of my constituents
because for it was on a spring morning
in 1971 when her majesty opened
chelmsford shopping center and most of
the village of chelsea wood turned out
to greet her in fact that day the royal
party was
running on a late schedule but the queen
was undeterred and she took her time to
speak to local residents
that same day the queen and the duke of
edinburgh were also shown the proposed
site of the national exhibition center
they would return five years later in
1976 to open the nec where excited
members of staff stood in the line to
greet her majesty and this is
particularly apt because the nec was a
major venue for the commonwealth games
her majesty always demonstrated kindness
generosity and dedication and i have my
own experience of this because in march
2007 when i was finishing off my degree
at the london school of economics i was
invited to meet her majesty on
commonwealth day i was nervous and i was
excited and she was very gracious with
her time and it was only later when i
asked a friend how did i do he said you
said a lot but none of it made any sense
i hope my tribute is better today but
her majesty never let on and she and
wish me all the best in my endeavors
for decades her majesty has been a
cool-headed constant steward of our
great nation she was always there when
we needed her she showed us what it
meant to keep calm and carry on
i'll never forget how in the pandemic
she gave reassurance the whole nation
and told us that we would meet again we
were blessed to have her and she really
was the best of us
she lived a dedicated life of service
and devotion to her husband her family
her country and the commonwealth and
every single one of us in this house
would do well to emulate her lifetime of
selflessness and public service
today we mourn a monarch and we pray for
her and as we reflect on her legacy and
we look to the future i say only this
may she rest in peace may we always be
grateful to have experienced her reign
to god we belong and to god we return
god save the king
chris law
thank you mr speaker and it's a pleasure
to follow uh the delightful tribute
given to the queen by ryan roble member
from meredith i'm on behalf of myself my
constituents in dundee west and all
peoples of the royal ancient borough of
dundee i'd like to pay tribute to her
majesty the queen and send my deepest
condolences to the royal family at this
difficult time
her majesty dedicated her life to public
service and having it seeded to the
throne an unexpected young age she has
reshaped the monarchy in the changing
generations that she has reigned and
she'll be remembered in history as
britain's longest serving monarch
throughout her reign she said with
dignity and compassion everyone that i
know personally that has met her has
spoken of her real and genuine warmth
the queen of course had a strong
scottish heritage the queen mother's
home was glam's castle in angus not far
from my city of dundee as a result her
majesty frequently visited visited her
maternal grandparents there as a child
indeed one of the earliest photographs
of the queen visiting dundee is as a
child shopping in webster's toy shop in
whitehall crescent with a grandmother
the countess of strathmore
throughout her lifetime she continued to
visit my city
and many of dundee's parks and public
spaces were officially opened by her
majesty
his then princess she officially opened
camperdom
camperdown park in 1946
and seven decades later 70 years she
unveiled a plaque to officially open
slicer gardens our city's redeveloped
waterfront in 2016.
buckingham palace was of course not the
only balcony that the queen went from
in 1969 she arrived by training to
dundee and visited dudup court one of
the city's 44 multi-story blocks while
there she was welcomed by a local dundee
family and wave from their balcony to
the crowds that gather below i'm also
told
that she stayed back for a cup of tea
thousands of people gathered to watch
the royal yacht britannia birth in the
city when she made the first royal visit
to dundee as queen in 1955 with the duke
of edinburgh and i know that thousands
will now wish to sign the book of
condolence that has been opened at
dundee city chambers to allow members of
the public the chance to express their
feelings at the death of her majesty
she will always be remembered in dundee
in scotland the commonwealth and the
world for her unwavering service that
has never ceased until the end
thank you ma'am and may your rest and
peace
thank you very much mr speaker when the
announcement was made yesterday of her
majesty passing my tears started
immediately there's been lots of
euphemisms for that in the houses the
this afternoon but i cried in the way
that i would someone that i was close to
and of course i'd never met her
i wish i had met her i'd once been in
the same room that was as close as i got
but it was too big a room there were too
many people she entered at the opposite
end to where i was and everybody swarmed
and i and i didn't stand a chance
but i did have the privilege of meeting
two members of her family including um
our new king who spoke so movingly
earlier this evening
and in them we saw what she had
inculcated in her family and in the
nation we saw the example that that she
set
and it's no surprise that the same words
are used over and over again in the
tributes about
duty and sacrifice and dedication and
selflessness she personified them
but we have also heard about passion
we've heard about her passion of course
for her family for her country
for horse racing for for her dogs but
about humor about mischief which we saw
at the olympics and which we saw
quite recently in the platinum jubilee
celebrations
with paddington bear and in those
celebrations which were just a few weeks
ago of course we all rise to speak on
behalf of our constituents and my
constituents of in wantage and didcot
showed the great love and devotion they
had to her with street parties all
across the four towns and 64 villages i
represent far too many for me to get to
all of them although i i tried to do my
best
we have been blessed and it's a
constituency with a long royal history
the birthplace of of alfred the great
and we have been blessed with visits
like every other part of the country to
wallingford to hawaii to open the
diamond light source
however good any of us think we are
visiting things in our constituency none
of us are anything like her majesty in
70 years or day after day visiting
things openings ceremonies at the peak
she was patron of more than 600
charities
that she supported
and we have lost the most impressive
servant to our nation that we will ever
see
and we should be forever thankful for
what she has given to us
and mr mr speaker winston churchill and
in saying that that should give you an
indication of how early that was in her
reign
but winston churchill said if all the
film
people all the film people
in all the world if they scoured the
globe
would not find someone as suited to the
part
how true that was
may she rest in peace and god saves the
king hey
bamboo
[Music]
mr
chorus
i'd like to pay tribute to her late
majesty the queen on behalf of myself
and my constituents of enfield southgate
in our grief we remember a lifetime
dedicated to extraordinary public
service
her steadfast commitment to the values
of duty public service and family
provided comfort to so many here and
around the world and my thoughts and
condolences and those of my constituents
are with the king and the royal family
at this most difficult time
as we all know the queen was the one
constant in our lives
at times of incredible change at times
of crises and during good times too she
was britain's reassuring and constant
presence
in 1953 the whole country joined in
celebration to mark the queen's
coronation
in enfield southgate i'm reliably
informed there were many local events to
mark the occasion including a local
parade procession and athletics games in
broomfield park
footage from this time is incredibly
poignant after thursday's news but also
after this summer's platinum jubilee
where communities were able to come
together once again to celebrate the
queen
in 1953 the queen's coronation speech
was broadcast over loud speakers in
bloomfield park but because of the rain
many listened at home on the radio
this summer we had no such problems we
had street parties across the borough
with bake-offs and crown competitions
and it was wonderful to bring
communities together in this way 70
years later
now today those events are all the more
moving as we pay tribute to the queen's
life and her service to our country
and i'm sure we will see the same sense
of togetherness again as the nation
mourns over the coming days
as our longest ever serving monarch like
most of us i do not remember her time
before queen elizabeth ii
in this time she saw 15 prime ministers
but somehow managed to stay above party
politics
as we know in this house that is no mean
feat
and for 70 years she embodied and
represented the nation with an
unwavering duty on the international
stage a symbol of stability when things
were changing
the outpouring of emotion
internationally we've seen since the
news is a testament to her success in
achieving this
she was not just well-regarded but loved
around the world
and this is something that i've
witnessed again and again while meeting
foreign representatives from other
nations who without fail will always pay
tribute to the queen
and those who had the pleasure of
meeting her will always share stories of
her kindness and warmth and her sense of
humor as we remember her late majesty i
will personally remember how she
continued to serve her country with duty
and kindness until the very end
the queen was an example for us all
may she rest in peace god save the king
i rise to express the admiration and
deep love of the people of rutland melt
in the vale and harbor villages for her
majesty in our heartfelt sympathies to
royal family
since her death our communities have
been sharing their stories of her and
their love
and we have been blessed with three
visits first in 1967 where she traveled
on the royal train with her beloved
phillip three thousand children awaited
her and she visited our oakham castle
there she presented a ceremonial
horseshoe because our tradition is the
first time a peer of the realm or a
majesty or any member of the royal
family visits our county they must
present a horseshoe she gave us an
enormous horseshoe and in the heart of
it a small horseshoe from one of her
racehorses which was very touching it
now hangs upside down which some say is
unluck unlucky but in rutland we say it
will stop the devil from bedding in and
it's now on display in our castle the
second time in 1984 where she visited
upingham and oakland schools and the
hospitals and janice and anne and
finally in 1996 where to enormous crowds
she visited melton mowbry walking up
nottingham street and of course she did
stop at year old pork pie shop
she then finished her visit by going to
raf cotsmall and these visits remain in
the hearts of our communities
i have to confess that the last few days
well the last it feels a lot longer
doesn't it was only yesterday
my tears have fallen most when there
have been stories of joy shared because
i think then it is that we see the great
love that we feel for her but it was
also when his majesty uses the word mama
which i think touched so many of us
but i also believe that this christmas
we will all shed tears again
because no christmas will ever be the
same again and i hope we will all raise
a drink for her at christmas
but finally my overriding memory
of yesterday and what will save me for
my life is that double rainbow that we
saw and the reason for that is i see it
as a sign of her majesty returning to
her love to philip to the side of her
beloved husband and him showing her the
way
because mr speaker
as with all ages of history the end of
an era brings a new dawn and on behalf
of all the people of rotten to melt and
i say simply
thank you mom and god save the king.
thank you mr speaker i rise today on
behalf of the people of aberdaven to pay
tribute to our late queen
and to send my deepest sympathy and
condolences to the royal family at this
time of loss and grief
the queen will always be remembered by
our nation and by the world as the
epitome of loyalty humility and grace
she always put service to her country
above all else and we shall never forget
her duty first no-nonsense approach to
everything that she did
her unique talent lay in her ability to
connect with the nation and to reflect
our thoughts our hopes and our fears
she inspired affection and respect and
she was a source of comfort to us all
the last seven decades have been times
of seismic political economic and social
change
and throughout these turbulent years her
majesty was a beacon of consistency and
stability
she never failed to steady the ship
she was the personification of keeping
calm and carrying on
indeed her leadership during the
pandemic was testament to this
in echoing the immortal words made
famous by dem virulin we will meet again
she evoked in her typically understated
manner the stoic spirit and measured
optimism that guided us through that
period of crisis and hardship
on behalf of my abrahavan constituents i
thanked the queen for all that she gave
to our country
and i convey my very best wishes to king
charles as he assumes his new
responsibilities and begins writing the
next chapter in our national story
long live the king and long live the
prince and princess of wales
thank you uh mr speaker
her majesty the queen has been a given
in our lives an anchor
as certain as the sun setting each day
but her star has set for one final time
and there is no worldly scale
big enough
to show the weight of our loss
i like many
felt that she would always
be there
on behalf of my dudley north
constituents i wish to express my
sincere
and deepest sympathies
to his majesty the royal family and
indeed the entire entirety of the royal
household
mr speaker her majesty embodied
everything we all aspire to stand for in
this place dedication to public service
dedication to family dedication to
people
the magnitude of what her majesty
delivered in her time for us all
is impossible to measure and
while i never had the privilege of
meeting her
i felt a presence there a guiding hand
one that was available to us all
including paddington bear
in dudley north
i mourn alongside my constituents a
community united in grief
her majesty first visited dudley in 1957
as a relatively new monarch to view the
beautiful coronation gardens dedicated
to her which coincidentally my
constituency office overlooks so i will
always have a physical reminder to
follow her example of dedication and
public service
fast forward some decades to the 70s but
ultimately the 90s
and her majesty found herself in dudley
once again
although a little higher in altitude at
dudley castle and zoo making her
making her the first monarch to visit
the castle since her first since her
namesake elizabeth the first in 1575.
her majesty was given a tour of the
center before unveiling a piece of
commemorative glass and receiving a
crystal key to the castle as a gift of
the bearer
many of the messages i have received are
those of constituents reminiscing her
visit
it is clear she left a lasting
impression
what is also clear
is that when god made our queen
he certainly broke the mold
we all take comfort in coming together
to remember the guiding light her
majesty has been to us all
long live the king
the morgan
thank you mr speaker as one of the most
recent mps to swear allegiance to the
queen i'm saddened and humbled to have
the honour of paying tribute to her once
again
on behalf of my north rupture
constituents and on behalf of them i
offer my condolences to the king and to
the rest of the royal family for their
sad loss today
many constituents have been in touch
over the last 24 hours to share their
sense of love their sense of loss but
most of all their gratitude for the
queen's devotion her leadership and her
warmth during her 70 years of public
service
while the nation is united in sorrow the
anecdotes shared here today and by my
constituents from north shropshire
have shown me that as well as the sorrow
we can celebrate her life with joy as
remember her today
i've smiled at some of the more senior
of my members
neighbours have shared memories of the
comet coronation back in 1953.
these memories are vivid and are still
fondly thought of seven decades on
every television wheeled out so that
neighbors friends and family members
could huddle together for a glimpse of
the gracious young queen and a whole
programme of celebrations in the in the
town of when which i was recently shown
an original program in perfect condition
i'm thankful that the platinum jubilee
provided the chance for these
communities to unite once again and show
the queen just how much she was loved
and continued to be into her 70th year
she was celebrated across north
shropshire from the soldiers of the
royal irish regiment based at turn hill
to the helicopter pilots being trained
at raf shorebury including her grandsons
the new prince of wales and prince
harrison a decade ago we're very
grateful to have welcomed her to both
sites
but from wemm to whitchurch ellesmere to
oswestry and market drayton we lit
beacons across the countryside as a
symbol of gratitude to our longest
serving monarch
and how appropriate this was
for queen elizabeth was a beacon of
stability to us all throughout these
seven decades
but now a new era begins
christmas this year will be very
different we will gather around our
televisions again but this time it will
be the speech of king charles iii and
not that of our queen
in north shropshire we will raise a
glass boat to both of them
in 1957 the 31 year old queen promised
to give these old islands her heart and
devotion
she stayed true to her word for every
minute of her 96 years and for this we
are all grateful
we hope she rests in peace
god save the king
sarah brittle thank you mr speaker now i
just want to join colleagues in
expressing my deepest sorrow at the
passing of her majesty queen elizabeth
ii second and the sorrow of my
constituents of heinbern hasland and our
condolences are with the king and the
royal family
it's difficult to be able to put into
words of grief and profound loss that is
felt but after the rainbows that's been
mentioned as i paid my own tribute last
night at the gates of buckingham palace
in the darkness the heavens had opened
and the rain poured
it felt as though the weather portrayed
our grief the nation's heart was broken
for many of us the queen is the only
monarch we've known it's hard to
underestimate the value of the stability
she gave this country and the nations
around the world for which she was head
of state
when our politics or our society
seemed so fraught the queen was a
constant in our lives a reminder of
strength dignity and stability a
reminder of what unites us
in 2012 we had the privilege of a royal
visit from her majesty queen elizabeth
and the duke of edinburgh during her
diamond jubilee i remember my own
personal memory of that day stood on the
balcony of atkinson market hall at the
age of 17 years old outside my dad's
cafe millie's as she came to greet us
her eyes twinkled and her work warmed
shun through the crowds gathered in the
thousands they smiled they sang and one
feeling that could be felt within the
crowd they loved
during her 1957 christmas address the
queen said that while she cannot lead us
into battle give us laws or administer
justice she could give us her heart and
her devotion
all these years later we can surely all
agree that she did just that
she was our greatest public servant our
greatest diplomat and our stability
she has been the true light in our lives
that none of us really believed would
ever go out
may she now rest in peace
thank you ma'am and god save the king
christian wake
yeah
thank you mr speaker and i'm both proud
and sorrowed although delighted to
follow a vulnerable friend and i
emphasize about word friend because
grief does bring people together i
imagine i speak for many when i say i've
taken some solace in hearing some other
tributes today than those who've
actually got to meet and know her
majesty
i was never fortunate enough to have met
her but it almost feels like i had just
like everyone else in this chamber
because
there was something similar and familiar
to all of us and we all take a bit of
her with us but i like to think that i
take it's the humility and the kindness
that everyone speaks about
this great and proud country went
through many trials and tribulations
during the elizabethan age but she was
one of the constant providing stability
through wartime as much as in peace and
as many have already alluded to
regardless of your political political
views her sense of service to this
country she loved is something to be
admired treasured as something we should
all be proud of
i know what i was doing when i was 25
years of age and i know i would not have
been able to take on the responsibility
of a country let alone a whole host of
them like a commonwealth i certainly
couldn't have helped strip an engine
either
but i'd also like to put on the record
the condolences
of my constituency of barry south the
townships of radcliffe whitefield and
prestwich along with myself and my
family and i particularly think to this
year's jubilee cell aggressions when my
daughter
nursery at the time came back home from
nursery so proud that she had learned
the national anthem so she did her
rendition for daddy
and she sang god save our normal queen
unfortunately the words weren't quite
quite right but the sentiment was there
she was no stranger to berry eva was her
majesty visiting as a young girl herself
in 1938 and visited a further six times
after that with her most recent visit in
1992 where she opened saint peter's
square metro link station and took a
ride to visit berrytown hall which she
had opened 38 years prior
what stood out for me most though about
her service wasn't just for the length
of what she did it's for the fact she
seemed to generally enjoy every single
moment of it
from historical meetings with world
leaders right down to visiting primary
school children she made everyone feel
like they were the only person meeting
her
she was a mother
a grandmother
a great grandmother
a wife a sister a rock to the nation but
more importantly a grandmother to a
nation she was all sorts to everyone but
she was always a queen the saddest thing
is that there are children born today
that will never know a queen let alone
the queen
finally i think all of my constituents
will agree with one simple message
thank you mom may our queen rest in
peace and long live a king james
thank you mr speaker and i rise in deep
sadness but with immense gratitude for
the life and the service of our beloved
late sovereign queen elizabeth
i firstly want to place on record the
love and respect of my constituents in
wolverhampton north east for her majesty
many have already contacted me about the
devastating sense of loss and grief they
feel at her majesty's passing and i
thank them for sharing their thoughts
with me it is an honor to pass them all
in this place
it's extraordinary that so many of us
who never met queen elizabeth can be so
affected by her death but for everyone
in wolverhampton in the united kingdom
and across the commonwealth she was a
huge presence in our lives
the queen visited wolverhampton several
times to our schools our factories
and i think my favorite story is from a
visit before i was born in 1962 her
first visit to molyneux
she was presenting colours to the north
and south staffordshire regiments and
the staffordshire yeomanry and she did
apologize to wolverhampton wanderers for
her high heels making marks on our
hallowed turf at molineux
uh thirty thousand wolfrunians cheered
her that day and i know the strength of
feeling for our monarch is is still as
as
deep today as it was then
for millions of us her majesty was a
constant presence at so many events in
our lives and every christmas i like
millions of people
felt the queen was in my living room
when surrounded by my family we waited
for her words every year
words of wisdom of comfort
um
last year at a last christmas address
she spoke about her upcoming platinum
jubilee
and how she hoped it would be
an opportunity for people everywhere to
enjoy a sense of togetherness
at so many jubilee events for her
majesty my neighbors became my friends
and she certainly succeeded at all the
events i attended in wolverhampton this
year for her platinum jubilee she
brought us all together
because of her majesty's age and because
we knew she was struggling with some ill
health i think the celebrations this
year were poignant as well as joyful and
i'm sure i'm not the only person who
through our smiles also shed a tear when
paddington bear thanked her majesty
for everything
she has united our nation once again um
on this sad occasion
she now unites us in national mourning
our thoughts must be for her beloved
family
uh the royal family and especially our
new king charles iii as he takes on such
responsibility
i hope the outpouring of love for her
late majesty will bring the royal family
some comfort over the coming days and
weeks
i want to express immense gratitude for
her life her many qualities she was a
shining example of strength and of
selflessness in public service may our
beloved queen elizabeth rest in peace
and rise in glory god save the king he's
understood
thank you speaker
this day is a day many of us should
never come but many of us believe will
also never happen i need not remind
members of her late majesties on waving
service as britain's longest-serving
monarch her calmness and stoicism
difficult times and the continuity and
stability she offered our country and
our people
she personified the virtues of loyalty
and humility
never complaining and setting a towering
example for world leaders future
monarchs and ordinary people alike
her majesty was the embodiment of our
nation's identity and for many people
she was the united kingdom
with uncanny ability to be unchanging it
also moved with the times
she epitomized the concept for
constitutional monarch and took this
responsibility seriously
thus cementing the role of the
constitutional monarchy in this country
remaining above politics is imparting
profound wisdom to innumerable prime
ministers and parliamentarians over
several decades
but it was not a constitutional link to
the lawmakers this land that made her
one of the greatest monarchs in our
history
but it was our finishing with every
single man woman and child in britain
and across the commonwealth
nowhere is this better exemplified than
during her visits but it was in places
like roller valley that her majesty
excelled
her visit to rother valley in 1977 was
an unrivalled success
she was greeted by over 7 000 children
from across the valley at more big
comprehensive school and on the mulberry
fields more than 20 schools and youth
organizations put on displays
countless rather valley children would
cherish the memories of this visit but
my favorite story is about a
ten-year-old girl from letwell who was
dressed in a purple velvet cloak with a
plea for the queen written on a
cardboard sign
it read
dear queen of england please crown me
queen of aston fence school love allison
as the queen passed she julie obliged
taking the sign her majesty asked
allison so you want to be crowned do you
then carefully picking up the homemade
crown held in a velvet cushion by
allison's page boy a seven-year-old boy
called matthew alton from woodhouse mill
her majesty regally placed it on
alison's head thus crowning her the
queen of aston fence school
but this anecdote like many across the
country encapsulates what her majesty
meant to rather valley the united
kingdom and the world
despite all the grandeur the pomp and
the ceremony and the serious
constitutional role she played her
majesty's most winning qualities were
humour a kindness and a famous
mischievous twinkle in her eye
she was a cultural icon but beneath it
all she was the nation's grandmother
she loved all of us and was beloved by
all of us in return
i send my deepest condolences to royal
family behalf of my own family natalie
stephanie charlotte and all the people
around the valley
eternal rest grant upon my lord and that
perpetual light shine upon her
may she rest in peace and i offer my
humble allegiance and loyalty to his
majesty king charles iii
god save the king
thank you mr speaker
her late majesty was always warmly
welcomed to northampton
and so the town mourns her passing most
sincerely looking over some of the old
coverage of royal visits to northampton
since the sad news yesterday it's clear
how much joy she brought on every
occasion
so many speakers from across the house
have succeeded in communicating the
almost magical combination of majesty
and personable friendliness
and yet within that one was always aware
of her sheer presence presence even
stood in a lay by with my dear mother
mrs sandra lua as an infant in 1977
waving a dot leaf and getting a wave
from the limousine in return
two of the occasions upon which i met
the majesty illustrate this duality the
800th 800th anniversary of the maundy
service in 2010
where she presented the ceremonial money
to another inspirational woman the late
sister mill wilde one of the last of the
methodist order of deaconesses
tradition dignity
majesty
the diamond jubilee two years later
there i met her majesty at a much less
formal event
and when introduced i i found myself for
reasons uh too obscure to detain the
house with tonight talking to her
about donuts
her majesty took it in typically good
part thankfully but i sensed rather than
saw
a certain look between the then lord
lieutenant also thankfully a friend of
mine and my wife
who had much to say about this
afterwards
personable cheerful filled with humanity
blending this with her dignity and
bearing was brilliantly described as
alchemy
by a colleague earlier today
so
i thank you mr speaker and mr deputy
speaker for your indulgence tonight it
really is appreciated and that of the
house staff as well it's meant a lot to
us to be able to do this this evening
and in conclusion may god bless the
majesty the queen
and keep her
safe
and god save the king
jeremy
speaker i add my name to the outpouring
of love affection and gratitude for the
life of her late majesty on behalf of
the people of broadland
it's a somber day as we grieve
so who would have thought that we would
have laughed so much as we've remembered
her extraordinary life
i've loved listening to the speeches of
colleagues as they've recalled their
mishaps with her majesty and through
those stories i've learned so much about
her deep graciousness
i have never been lucky enough to meet
her but i still grew up with her as part
of my family
for that was the impact of her life on
all of us
through her service
she reached into our homes and our
hearts
whatever else was going on
in our lives or in the country the queen
was always there
as steadfast anchor of of rightness
she did not represent the people
she embodied them
embodied them through her steady
selfless service
year after year decade after decade
by her life and how she lived it she
pointed out to all of us the real values
by which life should be lived
integrity
devout faithfulness
duty
we in return
have have demanded constant attention
constant attendance
constant access
irrespective of any difficulties in her
own life
often demanding the most
at the hardest times
and yet she never faltered
never step back
stay true to her young oath
what a wonderful woman what a wonderful
monarch
her heavy burden which she somehow
managed to wear so lightly
has now passed to the king
his wonderful speech to his peoples
today shows how he has shouldered it
may she rest in peace
god save the king
thank you mr speaker it's a solemn
honour to rise in this debate to pay
tribute to her late majesty the queen
both personally and on behalf of my
constituents in hartford and staltford
and it's humbling to follow so many very
wonderful and fine tributes that we've
heard throughout the day
the king himself in his moving address
made reference to the speech many others
uh in this chamber have mentioned
where his mother the late queen
made on her 21st birthday
a declaration that her whole life
whether it be long or short be devoted
to our service
we know now that her life was long and
that for every day of her seventy year
reign she magnificently honored that
solemn vow
in that same speech she also said
i am thinking especially today of all
the young men and women who were born
about the same time as myself and have
grown up like me in the terrible and
glorious years of the second world war
and it is also this alongside her
vow of devotion to duty which resonates
with me today
perhaps it's because she was speaking
about those
like my own parents now themselves in
their 90s and children of the east end
and of the blitz
and i'm struck more than ever that her
late majesty both as a person and as a
monarch represents a link between our
generations
she's a tangible human link to our
nation's past
it struggles but most of all to its
finest hour
and she's also a link to our own
individual pasts our personal and our
family's histories and we've heard many
of those stories here today
her ability to evoke the spirit of what
we rightly called the greatest
generation
gave us what in my view was the finest
speech of the covid crisis
she said that she hoped those who come
after us will say that the britons of
this generation were as strong as any
and of course she said we will meet
again
her late majesty personified that link
with our past and with the greatest
generation we shall not see her like
again
arthur balfour was prime minister in
1901
and addressed this chamber on the death
of queen victoria
he said then
that the end of a great epoch has come
upon us
with the passing of our queen the end of
a great historical epoch has indeed
passed
but we are all privileged to have lived
at least some of our lives in the great
second elizabethan age
we mourn her but we cherish her memory
and her lifetime of service
god bless her late majesty queen
elizabeth ii
and god save the king
thank you
mr speaker it is humbling to take part
in this very special session as we mourn
her late majesty queen elizabeth
ii we have heard powerful tributes we
have heard wonderful
words spoken
and as i have sat and reflected through
what is coming on ten and a half hours
of those wonderful
tributes
the thought that actually there may not
be the words
in our language
there may not actually be the phrases
powerful enough
to express
the sheer scale
of the significance
of the reign
of her late majesty to our country
to the overseas territories to the
commonwealth
and to the whole
world
but on behalf
of my constituents
the towns of buckingham prince's
risborough winslow and the villages that
surround those ancient market towns to
make up the buckingham constituency
i wish to pass on
my condolences
to the whole royal family
to our new king his royal highness
charles iii
to the new prince of wales
for the profound loss that they feel as
a family
and that we share
as a nation
her majesty
was gracious to visit my constituency on
a great number of occasions as i look
back
through the history books
special occasions that
when you look at the pictures you see
the joy on people's faces
as she joined them as she greeted them
there's a walk about in the town of
buckingham
when she visited
the university of buckingham
whilst lady thatcher
was its chancellor
a visit to wadstone
the pictures that hang on the newly
reopened stag pub in meant more of her
village of her visit to the village of
meant more
some time
ago
you could see the joy in people's faces
as she joined them
we have lost a most incredible lady
a world statesman
someone who's like i fear
we will not see
again
but from the great privilege of watching
his royal highness king charles iii on
the screen in this chamber earlier
i am full of hope
and confidence that he will carry on her
legacy that he will be
a great king
and so i say on behalf of all of my
constituents and myself
may her late majesty queen elizabeth ii
rest in peace
and god save the king
speaker and thank you for your
indulgence pause 10 o'clock for those of
us who've been here it's really
appreciated
it's privileged to follow so many
incredible tributes to her majesty queen
elizabeth
she was a committed public servant
fulfilling her promise to our nation
to serve us her whole life
service that was delivered with honor
duty and integrity
she stood
as an inspiration to us all
on behalf of the people of darlington
i want to send
sincere and heartfelt condolences to his
majesty king charles iii
and the whole royal family
throughout her long reign her late
majesty travelled more widely and met
more people than any other monarch
and her travels included two visits to
darlington
the first in 1967 her late majesty
and the duke of edinburgh visited
darlington on the 100th anniversary of
the town being awarded a royal charter
by her great great grandmother queen
victoria
and at the time granted supporters on
the town's courts of arms
at this time there were plans to
concrete over much of the town and
remove much of its victorian heritage
i understand that the royal party asked
a number of probing questions of these
plans which included the removal of our
clock tower
a clock tower which was inspired by the
elizabeth tower of this palace
i am pleased to say
that the plans were largely dropped and
our clock tower still stands proudly
over our town today
her late majesty returned to darlington
again in 2002
as part of her golden jubilee tour
and the town turned out in force to line
the streets and welcome her
there were so many floral offerings that
members of the scouts were needed to
help carry them all to the car
the crowds were so big that the palace
issued a statement the following day
noting the unexpectedly large crowds in
darlington
the queen was truly loved by the people
of darlington and she will be deeply
missed
just yesterday morning at auckland
castle i attended a ceremony for the
presentation of the queen's award for
voluntary service
to the community peer mentors in county
durham and darlington
recognising the public service and duty
in my constituency that her late majesty
embodied
we mourn her
we miss her
her place in history and her lasting
legacies are rightly assured
now reunited with her husband may she
rest in peace until she rises in glory
again
god save the king
luke evans
thank you mr speaker for allowing us to
sit late tonight
bosworth has an affinity and eternal
history with the monarchy after all we
had the battle of bosworth in august
1485 where we saw the death of richard
iii
and the crowning of henry vii so my
constituency has a palpable visible
history with the monarchy and it's still
there and proud today
and we've heard the description over and
over of duty
and i challenge any member in this house
to find a better person in british
history that personifies duty
to me
it's queen elizabeth the dutiful
now as a member of parliament we have
the honor of representing and reflecting
the opinions and feelings of our
constituents
and something that's never happened over
a thousand years of monarchy
is the ability to feel that immediately
due to social media
that is the chance for us to reflect the
feelings of the nation and i've been
struck
by a poem that's been sent to me by
several constituents and many
councillors and i'm sure it will have
graced your screens too and i'd like to
read it to you
because it's visceral and encapsulates
the feelings of the nation
philip came to me today
and said it's time to go
i looked at him
and smiled and as i whispered yes
i know
i then turned and looked behind me
and saw i was asleep
all the family were around me
and then i could hear them
weep i gently touched each shoulder
with philip by my side
and then i turned away and walked with
my angel husband as a guide
philip held my hand and he guided me on
the way to a world where kings and
queens are monarchs
every day
i was given a crown to wear
or a halo known by some
the difference is up here they're worn
by everyone
i felt a sense of peace my reign had
seen its end
70 years i'd served my country
as the people's dearest friend
thank you for the years
for all your time and love now i am one
of two again
in our palace up above
rest in peace
your majesty long live the king
thank you mr speaker and on behalf of
the people of hastings and rye i express
our sadness and grief at the death of
our beloved sovereign her majesty queen
elizabeth
her late majesty came to hastings and
leonard's 25 years ago filling local
residents with pride and joy and she
visited a number of places including
western's primary school the fisherman's
museum and opened prior meadow shopping
center she was presented with a winkle
by the winkle club
our queen spent her whole life dedicated
to her people
of the united kingdom and the
commonwealth a life she did not choose
herself but one which she was born to
and the burden of her birth with one
which she carried so diligently
dutifully and lovingly with the support
of her faith in god her beloved late
husband prince philip her family and her
people i want to thank her late majesty
for her life of selfless public service
her love her dedication her stoicism
her majesty shone a light to us all a
light which gave comfort to those in
need a light which gave hope to those in
despair and a light of unity to all her
peoples from across our four nations
she brought light where it was most
needed a beacon of stability to us in
this place
and i speak on behalf of the people of
hastings and rye when i express my
deepest sorrow at her majesty's passing
and extend our prayers for and
condolences to her family our royal
family with his accession to the throne
his majesty king charles iii will bring
in a new era and we offer him our
loyalty and love for a long and happy
reign long live the king
thank you very much indeed mr speaker on
behalf of the constituents of aylesbury
i convey deepest condolences to his
majesty the king and all members of the
royal family following the death of her
late majesty the queen
she played a huge part in the lives of
each and every one of us she was the
constant through good times and bad
celebrations and crises her tireless
dedication and unwavering service to our
nation her realms in the entire
commonwealth are unparalleled and they
will never be forgotten
elite majesty visited aylesbury on
several occasions during her 70 years on
the throne she came in 1962 as part of a
celebration of the 10th anniversary of
her accession when pavements thronged
with well-wishers and she popped into
the homes of two residents
she visited again in 1969 to open stoke
mandeville stadium the birthplace
of the paralympic movement
and her majesty came to aylesbury once
more to mark her golden jubilee in 2002.
the love and affection that we feel for
her in buckinghamshire was vividly
demonstrated across our county time and
time again and most recently during the
platinum jubilee celebrations coming
together for parades and picnics dog
shows tugs of war three-legged races
from the youngest child to the most
senior citizen people the length and
breadth of my constituency wanted to
demonstrate their gratitude and
appreciation for the commitment and duty
shown by the queen throughout her
incredible reign
mr speaker my own memories of her
majesty are i suspect very similar to
those of the vast majority of the public
because i never met her
and yet she was always there
i remember making a scrapbook on the
queen and her family for a cub scout
badge a tea party in my village for the
silver jubilee watching her name hms
duke of lancaster in glasgow and seeing
her on the royal barge during the
diamond jubilee flotilla
snatched glimpses
modest memories
yet the loss is still felt keenly
one singular honor that i was extremely
fortunate to receive though mr speaker
was to gain royal assent for a private
member spill i'd taken through this
place
i was humbled to have that privilege
just a few months ago the passing into
law of the approved premises substance
testing act a prorogation
in some ways the words
are a small formality
but in others they represent great
moment symbolizing the relationship
between parliament and sovereign a
relationship that we celebrate today
mr speaker we have heard wonderful and
eloquent
tributes
but no words will ever adequately
encapsulate her majesty's reign
let alone the profound loss and deep
sorrow that we feel today
our nation is poorer
for having lost her
but oh how much richer for having known
and loved her
may she rest in eternal peace
god save the king
mr speaker i think if one wanted to look
at an example of how much affection the
people of ipswich had for her late
majesty you would have needed to have
been an ipswich on the weekend of the
jubilee we've heard today that
apparently there is most parties in
twickenham than anywhere else in the
country i'm not entirely sure about that
i think i mean i'm not sure what the
measurement was but i think gibsons was
definitely strongly up there all
communities came together i remember my
jubilee card competition i thought my
christmas card competition was popular
until i had the jubilee car competition
where we had over a thousand entries and
the winner from ranley primary school
i was incredibly proud to uh receive her
her to have her car go to the queen
um
her late matches she visited ipswich
many times but there was two visits
really stand out for me one of them was
in 1961 to chantry at the time it was a
fledgling housing estate it's now became
the largest housing estate in europe it
now is a community of 15 to 20 000
people and it's a beating heart of
ipswich in our town they also think of
2002 her golden jubilee where she
visited the ipswich waterfront
that just indicates how much the town
has changed in her reign and also her
uncanny ability to time her visits which
gave her sense to people of ipswich she
was monitoring closely the town's
development and cared passionately about
her subjects she lived within that town
and that care and love was reciprocated
i must admit mr speaker but i'm a big
fan of i vow to be my country i'm also a
big fan of jerusalem on occasion i have
speculated that perhaps those absences
should have been our national anthem
right now mr speaker there is nothing i
wouldn't give
just to have sung god save the queen a
few more times maybe a few more years
nothing i wouldn't have done but right
now we need to ask ourselves what her
late majesty would want us to do
and what she'd want us to do is unify as
a country and come face to challenges
ahead and she wants to proudly proudly
see
god save
the king thank you very much mr speaker
dr ben spencer thank you mr speaker i
rise to speak on behalf of my
constituents in rene mead and way bridge
as we and the nation warns
her majesty queen elizabeth ii was an
inspirational figure who embodied
selfless service she provides stability
support and sucker in challenging times
ready and waybridge has the privilege to
be neighbor to her home in windsor and
my constituency is adorned with plaques
and scribes with her name
we have a statue of her majesty at the
runymid pleasure grounds
unveiled at the 800th anniversary of
magna carta which shows just how far
we've come in running meet since 1215.
her first public visit following
lockdown in march 2021
was to run medium weight bridge where
she attended the centenary of the royal
australian air forces at the air force
memorial itself opened by her in 1953
this is a fitting example of her
commitment to duty and service
throughout her reign
i sought the recent jubilee what she
meant to my constituents with all the
celebrations garden and street parties
and the lighting of the cherty beacons
one of the highlights of the jubilee for
me was my school visits where i saw
countless portraits of the queen created
by local school children mostly da
vinci's some picassos
and everyone demonstrating her majesty
and now as we mourn her passing the
scale of the impact on all of us the uk
and the commonwealth is clear
i believe that if we all aspire to have
even a fraction of the compassion
integrity dedication she displayed for
the world
we would be in a much better place
i hope that part of her legacy is that
each and every one of us use this time
to reflect on her example on what this
can teach us her attributes will live on
in the long tradition of the monarchy in
the reign of our new king king charles
iii
running medium waybridge sends its love
its thoughts its prayers to his majesty
the king and all the royal family if our
grief is raw
i cannot imagine the pain her family are
feeling
our queen was loved throughout the world
her legacy lives on
god save the king
scotland thank you mr speaker i rise
with great sadness to pay tribute to her
late majesty queen elizabeth ii on
behalf of myself
and of all of the people of blackpool
south
throughout her long reign queen
elizabeth was a figure of national pride
a symbol of stability of continuity and
an inspiration to so many myself
included
but just as importantly we must not
forget she was also a loving mother
grandmother and great-grandmother
it was just a couple of months ago that
i attended street parties across
blackpool for the platinum jubilee
the celebrations brought together people
from all backgrounds
all faiths people old and young a
testament to her ability to unite the
whole country and to keep the monarchy
at the forefront of our nation's life
during a reign that saw unparalleled
social change
she opened up the family to the general
public and made us feel as though we
knew her personally
and in return over the decades
we loved her and shared in her joy
and in her grief
most notably on the sad loss of her rock
prince philip only last year
those constituents of mine who had the
privilege of meeting her always without
exception spoke about her warmth
her humility and how she made them feel
so special
her late majesty was not likely to be
queen when she was born let alone to
become britain's longest reigning
monarch
but from the very beginning service to
her country was in her dna
her devotion to this country is
encapsulated in a remarkable speech on
just her 21st birthday
when she stated that we must give
nothing less than the whole of ourselves
and when she took on the noble motto i
serve
unquestionably she gave a whole of
herself to this country epitomised by
serving it to the very end and swearing
in her 15th prime minister
just three days ago
it will take a long time for the
tremendous sadness
felt by us all to pass
but we can be comforted by the way in
which she touched the hearts of so many
and served our glorious nation so well
the example that queen elizabeth set has
been instilled in king charles iii's own
sense of duty and service
at a time of immense sadness for him
personally
he has taken on responsibilities of the
crown and the leadership of our nation
and the commonwealth
our thoughts and prayers are with him
and we offer him our loyalty
and devotion at this difficult time
just as we know he will give it to us
as we move into a new era in this great
country's history her late majesty will
always remain
in our hearts
god rest her soul and god save the king
the culture
thank you mr speaker and can i extend my
thanks to you for allowing this uh
sitting to be extended for members who
want to pay tribute to do so and i know
i speak on behalf of all of my
constituents in warrington south when i
extend my heartfelt condolences to his
majesty king charles and the royal
family on this deeply sad occasion
yesterday was a day we all knew would
come
yet still can never quite envisage
happening and i think it's a testament
to her late majesty's longevity both
in life and as our queen that all of the
united kingdom and throughout the
commonwealth
we are deeply moved by the loss of the
one constant in our life
indeed last night when i walked along
the mile to buckingham palace that
affection was really evident
young and old different languages
all coming to lay flowers lighting
candles spontaneous rounds of applause
the national anthem being sung
people paying their respects
truly a queen for all the people
we are fortunate in warrington to have
had her late majesty come to visit on no
less than four occasions
way back in 1968 she was given a tour of
the newly refurbished bridge street in
1979 when she and her late husband the
duke of edinburgh toured the new golden
square shopping center and most recently
in 2012 when she and the duke opened the
orford park jubilee hub in the year
marking her 60th anniversary on the
throne
many members today have talked about the
twinkle in her eye
and i have to say looking at the
photographs from those visits that have
been republished today in the warrington
guardian
it's the impression that she leaves on
other people's faces that is really
striking and the true legacy of our
queen is the impact she had on so many
people
we will now inevitably look back at 2022
with great sadness
but we must also reflect on what joyous
occasions it was to mark the historic
platinum jubilee in each one of the many
events i went along to in warrington it
was clear how deeply she was held in
affection by the whole nation a mother a
grandmother a great grandmother and the
queen to each one of us that celebration
of her long reign over us allowed people
to come together and be part of a
community and share a special time
for now
as we mourn the passing of a truly great
monarch we wish our new king every
success as he assumes the mantle of
responsibility that is so diligently
being carried out by our late queen over
the past 70 years
on her 21st birthday then princess
elizabeth declared before us all that
her whole life whether it be long or
short would be devoted to our service
that life was long
and that service was certainly devoted
god bless her late majesty
and god save the king
dean russell thank you mr speaker and um
also may i thank you for extending the
day and to your team for staying so late
in the evening to allow these speeches
it is with great sadness that i rise to
pay tribute to her majesty the queen on
behalf of myself and my constituents
across watford we have heard loving
tributes from across the house today and
we all mourn her loss and will grieve
together
but what is grief
if not a reminder of the strength of our
everlasting love
and we did love our majesty
the queen
many of us never met her but as we have
heard today we all felt we knew her in
fact we loved her as if she were a
member of our own family
and many of us as we know often invited
her to our own christmas day after
dinner
our image has
been ever present in our lives like
family photos on our fireplaces we may
not always look at them but we're
reassured that they are there
and now
she is gone
but her legacy will last forever
for every tear we wipe away
the precious memory remains
as we've heard many of those memories
are from visits to our own
constituencies and i have stories from
my own constituency in watford too
in 1946 when she was still a princess
she visited the heart casio show
a heart show in category park in 1962
she alighted the royal train at watford
junction and in 1981 she visited palmer
to school
but in 1977 for her silver jubilee she
visited the rolls-royce factory in
leavesden
and mr speaker i admit to having a
special family connection to that uh
factory
because that is where my wife's parents
first met
and i share this because i still recall
the excitement and pride my in-laws had
when they received a letter from the
queen when they reached their diamond
wedding anniversary
now sadly my father-in-law john who was
married to pat has since passed away and
is always sadly missed but i can still
vividly recall the image of his proud
smile when he showed me the letter from
our wonderful queen
so perhaps therein lies the truth why
our grief is so strong for her majesty
it is because she connected with us so
personally and our memories feel like
those of family
she was yet a constant in a world of
change and yes her compassion brought us
humanity even when the world could seem
so cruel and yes her words of wisdom
brought hope even when all seemed so
lost but perhaps her majesty's true
majesty was that her unbounding kindness
made each of us feel like we mattered to
her
and that is why she mattered so deeply
to us
she was loved not just because of what
she was but because of who she was
our nation's very own great grandmother
our compass uh matriarch our guiding
light
so i say thank you mom
you were loved by us all and in your
honor we lovingly support your son and
heir king charles iii
god save the king
for junior cross
thank you very much mr speaker today we
are united in mourning our beloved queen
elizabeth ii for 70 years she has been a
source of stability and comfort she's
the only monarch that many of us have
known i begin my tribute by remembering
the warmth and joy that she brought to
so many of us our queen she knew how to
have fun and make us smile remember when
joined by her beloved corgis she teamed
up with double 07 to parachute into the
opening ceremony of the 2012 london
olympic games or when she took tea with
paddington bear earlier this year i
attended jubilee events across honest
mourn and saw there the joy that the
queen brought to people's lives with
people coming up to me from amlok to
pentrith sharing their personal
experiences of meeting the queen
as their head her majesty was immensely
proud of the professionalism and
dedication of our armed forces and i
know that the team at arya valley where
the queen came to visit her grandson and
honest man's veteran population will
feel immense pride in fulfilling their
oath of allegiance to her
the queen was a frequent visitor to
wales she visited the port of hollyhead
and maurice castle opened oriole morning
clan gave me on anglesey and was awarded
an honorary doctorate from nearby bangor
university
during her diamond jubilee visit to
wales she said i've traveled the length
and the breadth of this country during
my 60 years as your queen prince philip
and i have shared many of the joys and
sadnesses of the welsh people in that
time and i have always been struck by
your sense of pride and your undimmed
optimism
her majesty's dedication to service and
her contribution to public life are
unparalleled she provided inspiration to
millions of women aspiring to the
highest officers she was a patron for
girl guiding and a long-serving member
of the wi which had its first meeting on
anglesey
we've shared the ups and downs of her
life as she danced with us in victory
and success and mourned with us at times
of grief her sorrow at the loss of her
devoted husband prince philip was felt
by us all and although our sense of loss
is immense we must take comfort that she
is once more at his side
and as our united kingdom moves into a
new era i welcome the announcement by
our new king today that his son prince
william who began his married life on
angus where he was stationed as an raf
search and rescue helicopter pilot will
become our next prince of wales
on behalf of the people of honest mourn
may i say jochenval and express
my sincere thanks for a life well lived
and send our condolences to her family
god save the king and god bless the
prince and princess of wales
and we finally have louis
thank you mr speaker very much um a
wonderful life of duty and service
and an inspiration to generations of
people across the world
it is a huge honor for me to stand and
pay tribute to the queen on the behalf
of people in old betsy and sitka and
also my family here in the uk
and overseas in canada
as a community country and commonwealth
we now come together to mourn the loss
of our queen
the ever present in our lives whether
that be on national occasions
singing the national anthem at public
and sporting events or my personally
fondest memories of watching the queen's
speech over family christmas dinner
we all have our own personal and shared
memories of the queen who will let
forever be in our hearts
i'm immensely proud to have discovered
in the build-up to the platinum jubilee
that an online poll confirmed old bexley
and sidcup my home as the most royalist
constituency
now when the french journalist asking
for an interview told me this
i stopped and thought about my own
experiences locally both growing up and
now
similar to colleagues at every primary
school visit the first question asks
have you met the queen
at most community events as far back as
i can remember what do we do
we stand together and we sing the
national anthem
experiences which i'm sure are shared
across the country and little did i know
when i sang the national anthem with the
ambassador for nepal last week at the
community event with our brilliant
bexley nepalese gurkhas and nepalese
community literally i know that one of
the last times that i would have the
pleasure of singing god save the queen
during the wonderful platinum jubilee
celebrations there were over 140
official street parties in bexley which
i understand was one of the highest in
london reflecting how cherished her
majesty is locally it was my immense
privilege to attend many of these
community events
i also remember the excitement when the
queen last visited the london borough of
bexley in 2005 to officially reopen
danson house which is in my right
honourable friend for bex even
crawford's constituency just over the
border from mine where she was greeted
by crowds of well-wishers
but it's also important to remember a
previous visit to bexley which was in
1953 to irith the honourable member for
era from thames media's constituency
after the devastating floods which is a
reminder of how the queen was there for
us throughout the good times but also
the bad and the way her presence brought
both comfort and hope to people at times
of concerns in an ever-changing world
the queen was an inspiration to millions
around the world
a fashion and sporting icon for a love
of the horses
the mother and grandmother of our great
nation
and who can forget the corgi emojis from
the platinum jubilee which highlighted
the evolution of technology during her
reign and how she embraced it i think i
found something no one said so far in 11
hours there
mr speaker
rest in peace your majesty
as a working-class lad from bexley it
was my greatest honor to swear i know
for allegiance to you
when entering this place
and you make us all proud to be british
and in my case an englishman
we will continue to serve loyally your
air and son king jules king charles iii
and all the royal family are in our
faults
and prayers on the behalf of the people
of old bexie and syd cup i say god save
the king
can i just say
this is when the house is at its best
when it is united in grief that brings
us together with so many stories and
memories that's been paid in such moving
tributes
can i say we've had 182
contributions and tributes today and
it's a big thank you to all but it's a
big thank you to the staff of this house
the police the security the catering and
everybody involved
and especially the clerks in the fine
wings today
and can i say
thank you to all what you've done i now
come to the motion of the sittings of
the house minister to move
on this sad day mr speaker i beg to move
to sittings of the house motion
the question is on the order paper as
many of that opinion say aye
the eyes have it the eyes have it order
order
a german lassen
okay have you moved no there is no
german
when did the pin say aye
contrary no the out of the house thank
you sergeant